e
okay
thank
thank you Mr chair uh for the books um
I'm representative Linda Tanner I
represent Sullivan District nine the
towns of planfield Cornish Grantham Cen
Newport Springfield sunap and
unity um I'm in my fourth term on the
education committee and three out of
those four
terms uh actually um I received when I
while I was working on the education
committee I received the annotated
education laws um for each bium uh last
last term uh we did not receive those
laws and I had requested of course it
was a unusual by any of because it was
cut short um but I requested those laws
several times the booklet um I find it
very helpful I'm not a lawyer um I'm a
former school teacher and um
it's very important for me um
particularly at my age I guess also that
I have something in writing that I can
kind of look at and go through and um I
found the annotated version of the law
uh very important and very informative
because it told me about the Amendments
and it told me about court cases and
that sort of thing so I I found it very
important um I don't know if the house
fairy just showed up all of a sudden um
before this bill came up on the on the
table but voila yesterday um big cartons
rolled into our um secretary's office
and um we were handed the new annotated
versions which is what I requested in
this bill um I think the bill is still
important even though you may think
because you got the booklets that it's
kind of a moot case um I think that um
so much in the
past I don't know four years five years
uh we we've
seen what is usual and customary
procedure what is common courtesy um
Unwritten rules um just kind of Fall by
the wayside and and uh it's been a real
wakeup call when you say Really they can
do that um and this is one of those
things that um I think has been a
courtesy thing it's never been in
statute before so I think it's important
that we go through this law this bill um
I've handed out a a an amendment to the
bill because I realized that um you know
even though I'm over the hill there's a
lot of young people coming up thankfully
and they use portable storage devices
thumb drives or flash drives as as you
see and certainly it's more cost
effective to um the people that are
doing this um and talking about cost
Effectiveness when I got my bill back
and it had an FN on it and it was uh I
looked at it and the first thing that
jumped out of at me was the $10,000 and
I thought that's like $400 a book I
don't I didn't really think a paperback
book uh even how big they were was going
to be $400 so I did call the Department
of Education um attorney Fenton uh
talked me down off the 10,000 and and uh
uh assured me that it didn't cost $400 a
book and um we had a a quite a good
conversation about it the other part of
this bill or the amendment is that I
also talked to a couple of
superintendant uh in my area about how
they found out how they were able to
access rsas on education and the changes
on
education um and if they had to have a
quick look up how they did that and of
course they have you know lawyers that
they can call um school districts do but
I'm sure they try to do that as little
as possible knowing how much an hour uh
they probably get charged but they one
superintendent said Gee I you know a few
years back I remember that they used to
send us flash drives and or the thumb
drives or the portable storage devices
um so I in the amendment I I uh put in
there that um the uh representative or
senator may request uh you know in
either format and that um the
superintendent receive a flash drive of
the new uh annotated laws at the
beginning of the bium
uh I think it's important we're all
working from the same place so that's my
testimony and I'm willing to take
questions thank you Mr chairman are you
aware also that um the book is what we
really need because we can't use our
laptops and whatnot while we're at
hearing so it's hard to look up with a
thumb drive um yeah I I think that's
probably true um I you know the thing
about uh looking up uh I know the
website has been improved and and it's
got the laws on it um they're just not
annotated
yeah
right
yes uh and with my discussion with
attorney Fenton who's here in attendance
this morning thank you for coming um we
discussed the the um possibility um and
the good probability that we could
actually get a a print out of the new
rsas at the end of the first year of the
bium um as they apply to education
because that's that's the other thing
the book is you know a two-year book and
uh we do have changes after the first
bium or the first year of the bium um
and she said that that would be readily
available is that correct um and my
other my other thought um on this bill
was about the uh education rules um
which have still confused me about um
you know exactly I'm not exactly sure
how all those turn around and come back
to us but um certainly there are
education rules that I would like to
have uh the ability to look up easily
and I find the Department of Education
website although it's beautiful um is
sometimes very difficult for me to
navigate and it again it may be my age
but um I've heard it from some other
people that they've had a little
difficulty finding laws and rules as
they're made up so uh certainly if we
could get a flash drive um portable
storage device um for the rules the
education rules um or at least the
changes the current changes I think that
would be helpful as
well
sorry I didn't put my red button on my
phone which is what I use to access all
of that stuff I would love to put the
the book in my phone so that because
it's annotated right and that way and do
you so my question is do you in your
conversation have any idea when they'll
get us that thumb drive uh no but I
think after I finish that uh you can ask
attorney Fenton to come up and and she
evidently has the answers to to some of
them or at least knows where to get them
um I think the other the other issue is
that uh I remember you know the old
books like you chairman lad talked about
yesterday were about three times the
size of the one that you today for the
new people and um Jim Grenier used to
bring his book every day and he had like
I bet you a h hundred of little tabs on
it where different different laws were
um and I really appreciated at that time
I I think it was maybe the second term
on the education committee um attorney
Fenton actually came with an index of
here's where these things are that we're
we've been talking about a lot of things
for Education are and it was very inform
ative so perhaps you can ask her if
she'd be willing to do a little um index
for us as well thank you thank you very
much would you believe that I have back
to 2008 with those little sticky notes
all through it yellow marks all through
it pencil and it that is where I go back
to reference especially the annotated
versions to find out the history of when
these things occurred that's right
that's very important it's very
important our next speaker is from the
Department yes represent
Hall
thank you Mr chair um I just have a
question about um
representative taner about the portable
data storage device and I'm wondering if
um possibly when it says provide a
physical copy and if it just said
electronic copy repr Hall can you move
that mic a little bit closer to your
speech I'm just wondering about
electronic copy I'm just thinking down
the road flash drives people don't even
use them you know or they might not use
them they use them now and if you just
left an electronic that it could be wide
open to whatever technolog is available
next year or the it doesn't really
change the intent right of the U I think
that's um thank you for the the question
I think that the portable data storage
devices uh is kind of um when when I
went to OS I asked for a flash drive and
this is what they came up with and I
think uh they were trying to cover some
of those bases as well but um certainly
in in the future I think we can you know
if it becomes a problem um and one of
the two of us is around then I think we
can offer another amendment okay thank
you representative Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman represent tan thank you uh for
bringing this forward uh just a quick
question when uh chiny fent and walked
you off the cliff did she give you a
ballpark estimate what the cost of it um
yes uh she did uh she said uh about $105
per book um I'm not sure if that was the
huge one or the or the
uh annotated the the the vision that we
have is the the big books had all kinds
of laws about uh camps and about the
state of New Hampshire how it was run I
mean they were they were referenced
across with education but they really
were ancillary so um this I think is a
more condensed version um of the of the
book it certainly isn't like I said the
three three stories high um and uh as
you know a true attorney she kind of
couched it with you know prices go up
all the
time thank you repres thank you chman
thank you very much uh one more
represent Cornell I don't know if it's
it's really a question but I know a lot
of the newer people to the committee
aren't here and I don't know have has
there been an orientation so they
actually know what we're talking about
and what the book
is generally speaking in response to
that um when we uh have our first
meeting as an education committee at the
beginning of the bium we have in the
past had these materials or at least had
them within a month or two afterwards
and when they are they're handed out
these books came back to us I saw them
on the desk in here but we didn't have
any hearings or exec sessions this last
summer so they sat there uh I believe I
did mention it somewhere along the way
to some groups of folks that came in on
either on other uh committees or
commissions and said we have these books
upstairs in the administrator go take
one uh but they weren't going to mail
these things out to us U no I I was
totally unaware they were available or
even like I said I thought it was just
the house Fury that showed up with them
the other day no no they they have been
available and I did make it known to
when we were looking at CTE when we were
looking at the school building uh deal
where the infrastruct funds that built
to support what you know that
legislation we did mention they upstairs
however um the only way of getting them
would be to drive in and get that book
and it's it's there's a lot of issues
with this whole thing you know because I
know that I bought a thumb drive the
other day for my insurance company they
want to see what the inside of my house
looked like for the homeowner policy I
got a thumb drive came home and I
couldn't put the thumb drive in my
computer so it's then I I have to send
it all by phone or whatever so it our
technology is changing so rapidly um
your your whole intent here is wonderful
and we've got to look figure out how to
make it work so we become familiar with
what's what we're doing and what we have
done in the past so if there's no more
questions for the sponsor the bill right
now we can invite Diana up and um hear
from the Department what their plan is
to make this thing
work thank you
y representative Tanner I would testify
with my book
it's really important to have props
right so good morning for the record my
name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education it's
nice to see everyone um so there is a
long standing history with the book when
I began uh with the Department back in
2015 it was quite thick and voluminous
um the joke I always made was the reason
I did criminal law before education was
that we had a thinner book um but if you
looked through that book there were
Provisions that were just not necessary
there was a provision on homicide there
were provisions on camps it just wasn't
necessarily relevant so my co-counsel
and I at the department recently went
through and we called out what was not
necessary and um we call well we're
lawyers so we use fancy terms like we
call one book The Big Book and the other
book the little book and I hope those
terms are easily accessible and
translatable um but this is what happens
when two lawyers hang out together so we
have the big book and the little book
the little book costs uh $105 to publish
as representative Tanner testified
to not only will the price go up and I
think that's expected across the board
but more importantly we're not sure if
the publisher will continue to publish
the book it is not profitable for the
publisher and that is outside of of our
control so that is a caveat that I
wanted to share with this committee um
however I will be the first to say and I
told this representative Tanner I
understand the need and the desire to
have the book uh no one uses their book
more than I do so I can certainly um
agree with that as for the rules
um the rules are a little trickier and
one of the reasons is not only do we
have so many rules as is evident by our
website but my concern in publishing
them we can publish them as a state
agency we have uh a publishing I don't
know if it's a company but it's a statun
organization that does all the
publishing um it's the reason you have
all the bills printed here that is a
state agency we can work with them to
publish it however when it comes to our
rules I think it's important to realize
that each set of rules has a different
expiration date so my concern about
publishing them as one volume is that
every section is going to be run its
course at a different time one thing we
did do uh in the past which you're
probably familiar with is we did publish
in print the code of conduct which was
passed by this committee um back in 2017
I believe and the reason we did that is
because it directly affects Educators
credentials we did not want it to just
be on our website as another link so we
have actively publish those books we
also publish um actively publish the
special ed rules every time that those
are done so rules are done on a 10e
cycle um I think the possibility the
more feasible possibility because the
fiscal note that
$10,000 that really comes from the
anticipatory uh cost of the rules the
books are a lesser cost at
$105 but I think one possible solution
is to pick an area uh whether it's CTE
or credentialing or minimum standards
and have those rules
published I that's how I think that
could be
feasible I'm happy to take any questions
I have I have a question first um when
we had a bill a little while ago dealing
with uh personal finance
literacy that is in the rules it's not
in the
statute so in order for us to know when
we're preparing legislation or hearing
from folks in the field we'd like or
from the business people that want
financial literacy we have to go down
and Chase down and get on the web now
and and look for that area within in
rule making my concern is that the last
time IED the rules and I always carry
the rules with me but I I can't recall
how many years ago when we had the issue
where the rules weren't we there was a
new change came forward in
306 and the new rules could not go into
effect seeing that um we we it had
missed that 10-year de uh date for
Renewal and so we flipped back the old
ones but the new rules were already
printed in the book and so then we had
to reprint saying no you go back to the
prior year rules that was back I think
when you either came on board or Aaron
was still here or there how can we get
these rules annually like we used to or
by anually for our committee we used to
get a book which which the rules went
especially 306 which is the most
important ones uh dealing with the
approv approval of public school
education how can we get a copy that
provided to us each bium a hard
copy those can be published as I
mentioned um so I a couple of things
that I want to just unpack from uh the
the question and thank you for the
question um the department cannot engage
in rule making without statutory
authority to do so and that's 541a so
anytime you see a statute that said that
says rulle making it will have the
associated statutory number so it
surprises me that there are rules
without that statutory Authority that
should not exist um however more to the
point if the committee requests that we
publish a certain section of the rules
minimum standards School approval I I
think that is feasible to do but there
will be an Associated cost and again in
the fiscal note we came up with that
amount of $10,000 just based upon the
the amount of rules that we
have just in response to that
followup it was very informative for us
to have that book if we could open it up
and figure out where we were and in fact
that that part I just spoke to dealt
with the required courses that had to be
taken for graduation in high school and
it was listed under the social studies
where you had economics and some of the
other and it then it went into personal
finance it was not in statute that's one
of the reason why we brought forward
legislation to put fin personal finance
literacy into statute which I don't
believe we have done yet and U so so I I
think we all need a copy that when we
start out and work here because
oftentimes we are referencing Rule and
we don't have anything that's there for
us to look at other than getting on the
web and then we're searching where to
find it on the web which is oftentimes
difficult and and I I do not dis
disagree at all I love paper copies and
books myself um the testimony from the
Department is simply to be mindful that
we will
need the the monetary support in order
to print those those copies so the
Department's happy to provide that
information but it will certainly come
at a cost but we can work with the state
publisher and and provide those books of
rules they're very helpful to have and
it is the law um so I can certainly
understand why the committee would want
that information we have to be mindful
that there has to be that fiscal cost
associated with that okay I can allow
others to have some questions here
representative yes Mary
Beth thank you I have two unrelated
questions but let me start with the
first we know that the state has
publishing facilities on store Street if
uh Thompson reuter stops publishing this
can we just get the state to publish
it it's possible I don't want to speak
for the publishing um the state
publishing group because they I
I'm hesitant to speak for them but is
that a possibility yes and I appreciate
that idea okay my second one is I think
I'm the only other lawyer sitting at
this table and so my question is a
little bit more inside baseball but um I
noticed that there's no case law in here
like you would find in the real rsas and
that apparently was a conscious choice
but case law in my 14 years here has
proven sometimes critical to
understanding what's going on in
statutes and I'm wondering why the case
law is not
shown um
I'm just looking at my version of the
book because I agree with you I like the
case on I don't think you have to be a
lawyer to appreciate how the court has
interpreted something uh I I can't speak
to why the decision was made for that
particular book that's outside of my uh
knowledge base um might have been a a
publishing decision okay well thank you
thank you can I just follow up on that
because that's a very important Point
we've dealt with various types of uh uh
educational issues sending children to
another school district when I went to
look up the Lisbon case regarding
manifest education it was in the old
books not in this book that the case law
is extremely important when we're
dealing with Claremont issues and others
right now it it belongs in our
books represent cordelli thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you uh attorney Fenton
um in terms of rules I think even more
important um part is special education
there is a lot in special education
rules that is not in statute nor in
federal law and there is a statute
specifically granting the department the
ability to make rules without a statute
behind them um so I think having special
ed rules um is uh even even more
important than um many of the other
areas uh well again I I don't disagree
um my understanding is that when the
special ed rules were revised which was
about 2015
2016 um pursuant to the idea money the
department did publish the the special
ed rules um because I think it's exactly
what you testified to part of your
question just the importance of them and
the complexity of them so I I do believe
those books are available I have seen
them I have one I I'm not sure what the
exact distribution is but if what this
committee is really asking for is a copy
of those books I can certainly speak
with Becky fet and see if I can provide
those I would also suggest I think they
have this down in Senate education they
have a bookshelf with some of the the
books on it the Senate books and the
rule books and so that might be a
possible solution as well um Everyone
likes to have their own own book I write
my name on mine so I certainly
understand that but just in terms of
having it as a reference that might be a
a reasonable approach as well it used to
be sop standard operating procedure that
they were handed out to members of the
committee at the first you know day we
met B the special ed rules the rules for
school approval um all that we we got
copies and that somehow stopped and it
stopped I would go back at least six or
seven eight years ago with stopped
coming like that and I know that various
chairs been here have had that concern
so I'm glad you're here today listening
to US Representative luno thanks thanks
very much Mr chair and thanks very much
um attorney Penton for joining us this
morning so um you've you've sort of laid
out some some logistical concerns with
you know in terms of printing
books um uh the loss of uh the absence
of case law
um in in at least the these copies here
and and also um the possibility of
printing rules but how does it work for
I mean outside of the legislature how
does it work for school administrators
and school
boards yeah thank you for the question
um I know when I first started six years
ago at the
department we would get a huge order of
these law books um there would be very
various types of these law books over
the years some of them had the case laws
others didn't I believe that is a
publishing decision I don't think that's
coming from us we're kind of at the beck
and call and the whim of the publisher
um historically representative luno the
department minor Shams we would provide
a copy of the book to every U and I
think over time um that has just changed
um and I don't I can't speak to the
exact reason for that change I don't
know if it was a cost or a Personnel
change I'm not sure and moving forward
to be honest with you I'm not sure how
the the saus now receive that
information that might be on them to to
seek that out um I think the reality is
we had an issue with the publisher the
publisher indicated they didn't want to
publish these books anymore and that
changed a lot of our former practice and
we're seeing the results of that for
that that change in
practice um so we can certainly you know
look into how that is that is handled
because the testimony is clear that
everyone appreciates the information and
it's important to have we the department
doesn't disagree with that at all
representative
Mullen thank you Mr chair and welcome
back uh attorney Fenton uh so my concern
I want to go back to something that
representative lad referenced to earlier
uh my concern has to do with updating
the rsas online I don't know whether or
not this is something that you feel
comfortable speaking to but I'm curious
as to what the process is for
updating the electronic version of the
rsas because I um feel relatively
comfortable on a computer and I find
it super circumventing to have to go to
Google to figure out how to uh get the
inside information that I need when I'm
considering some change or a new law so
I if you wouldn't mind commenting on
that sure I mean I can certainly uh
agree with where you're coming from I I
myself and the department have nothing
to do with updating the laws on the
website I would anticipate that um the
state has and this is pure speculation
on my part but my guess is um the state
has a contract with either wlaw or Lexus
Nexus those are the two big legal
publishing companies um that would then
update update the laws on the website so
I think that is all kind of behind the
scenes thing uh the joke in law school
was everyone who couldn't pass the bar
went to work for one of the publishing
companies that then updated the laws and
I see the fellow attorney nodding her
head which always makes me feel good um
so I think that's that's what you're
seeing that has nothing to do with the
department so just a followup if you
will Mr chair um attorney Fenton I think
uh you would agree that there are times
when I contact you to ask you to send me
the information that I need because I
can't find it somewhere um I do agree
with that is there is there I right I
like to make sure you have work to do
attorney Fenton I appreciate that yes so
is there where do you go to
electronically get if you will the
updated information on an RSA that might
have recently been enacted uh well I
just to be clear I I thought you were
calling me because you liked me so now I
I have to rethink a lot of things in my
life but um in terms of where do I go um
I I do get copies of this book every
January I'm not sure where my most
recent copy is I uh the department
through the department of Ed I have a
subscription to um Lexus Nexus and so I
can go on to that website that Search
tool um that is a uh something that we
subscribe to when I first started the
department we did not have Westlaw we
did not did not have Lexus Nexus and I
said in order to do my job I need one of
those search tools so we have a contract
with them um and myself and the other
attorney and my assistant have access to
it um and I don't
know we also have I have a New Hampshire
uh what is it the New Hampshire bar has
uh a Search tool tool similar to that
um I I will tell you historically when I
worked with law enforcement I got
everyone in law enforcement access to
the New Hampshire bar Search tool which
is very similar to West law and and
Lexus Nexus I don't even know if that
exists anymore but if that's something
the committee would like me to look into
I'm happy to do it we did it for law
enforcement I don't see why we couldn't
do it for for the legislature um I did
it once I certainly would appreciate
that anything you can do to help us it's
appreciated I'd be happy to do that I I
can't make any promises but we've done
it before successfully so okay rep
representative Porter thank you Mr chair
and thank you um M Fenton this is my
first time on education I'm new um and I
admit even though I've been in the
legislature for a while I still can't
figure out how to find what I'm looking
for in the rsas and I know this morning
I was late because I spent about 25
minutes trying to find out the uh
particulars of the education Freedom
account rules and regulations um and I
couldn't find them I could find them in
the bills but I couldn't find them
because I didn't know unless I looked
through House Bill two where I was going
to find those so what recommendation do
you have for those of us NE fites at
this to help us before we get all these
other helps just go to Google should I
have Googled is that what I should have
done I could have Googled it okay so
it's out there it's just not
here well thank you for the question I I
do think um I mean even as a lawyer I
have a hard time finding things so it's
not because you're new it's just
challenging at times
um I would perhaps
suggest because I think the lift to say
publish all the rules would would be too
much of a heavy lift but perhaps it
makes sense to say every time a new rule
is passed a rule in in a particular area
such as education Freedom accounts
perhaps there is a publishing
requirement and a distribution
requirement that is what I see as as a
reasonable solution and and but it would
have to have a fiscal note because that
is a cost that the department can't just
absorb um and we would have to be
mindful that I think personnel-wise we
could absorb the Personnel cost but the
cost of the publishing and the printing
would be additional and that would be my
concern is that the department does do
an enormous amount of rule making um and
and production in that sense but I think
it is a reasonable request when these
rules are finalized and and adopted um
and I would like to go back to something
representative Tanner said during her
testimony is that if this committee is
interested in in further further
explanation on the rul making process
which can be AIT bit mysterious at times
we the department would be happy to to
do a brief presentation on
that thank thank you very much uh
representative
B and represent lus thank you Mr
chairman thanks even taking the question
you said the Publishers are not going to
publish but is it the same publisher for
all our committees or does every
committee have a different publisher
criminal justice and I know this is
still probably the biggest book of all
of them how were all the others
published the
same it's a little bit out of my area of
knowledge but I do believe that it's
it's similar Publishers and yes we get
the criminal justice books um every year
yeah uh all I can tell you is what I've
heard is that the publisher has
indicated not promised not stated it's
just indicated that they might not be
publishing this moving forward um and
that is nothing to do with the
Department that's right outside of our
control than represent like
us yes if we have the big book from what
three years ago and we have the little
book from this
year um will we have except for the case
law will we have all of those things
that you were talking about camps and
you know whatever so like if we want
those things we can just go back to the
big big the older big book or have they
changed uh you can certainly refer to
the big book for those sections that are
no longer in the smaller book but I will
tell you that anytime you refer to Old
Law you
are you taking your life in your hand so
to speak you should be shepher ising and
and getting the most uh recent upto-date
um laws and I I do think the reality is
there have been significant
changes even in the past the six years
that I've been here this book changes
all the time and so I I personally would
never rely on an on an old law book for
reference one more question then we're
gonna move on to next go ahead
representative this is more a comment
than a question but I'm old and I went
to law school before we had all the
electronic stuff and I have sort of
stuck by using hard copy books we have a
set of the rsas right there that I pull
all the time in every committee I've
ever been on and they are updated they
have the new law in the book and they
have the case law in the rsas so every
one of these committee rooms has a
current set of laws in them and I can
see some sort of case law on top I'm not
sure what's over there but we but these
rooms all have RSA so we have current
law in this book and I'll help anybody
with hard copy because I'm much more
confident on hard copy than I am on Lex
is Nexus or anything else so I'm just
trying to say some of this is already
here we're talking about not having it
but we do have it and we don't have the
rules and what I would say to add to
that is it would be great if we had a
copy of the rules over there for this
committee at least because the rules are
so crucial in education so even one copy
of the rules in the room would be a
great reference point that we can pull
out and as I have done in other
committees and just used during a
hearing when it a particular subject
comes up so I know it's not a question
but I'm just trying to make clarify what
I'm hearing in the room well I
think the the uh we do have out in the
office here also all the statutory books
here annotated books going way back I
would say 20076 go they're all on a
shelf out there you can go back year by
year there's one copy of each that's
very helpful but the rules are also
something that we used to receive that
we don't I think that's extremely
important that we have copies of that um
so I I think where you you're going
you're hearing our
concerns and it's just going to make our
job better if we can have access to this
information I agree if we're looking for
some little minuscule area that we did
in hb2 which is a bill of what 100 plus
Pages you got to search through that to
find it and you have to go on the web
and look the bill up to find out what
exactly is in it because you're not
going to find it in statute yet
the issue of uh the uh B the the buses
on the infrastructure
monies that that's not in in in on the
web yet and yet I can go back and find
it under the bill that makes it very
difficult for a person that's trying to
write legislation or respond to a person
in the public with current information
so we need some help and I we'd
appreciate working with you on this
absolutely the department looks forward
to
that thank you very much if there's not
any other questions we're going to close
this hearing I think we've communicated
Our concern and I thank the sponsor for
bringing this bill in uh we will now
move in could we get pink cards from our
two
testifiers good
point okay so we're now ready to go on
to the second bill today that be a
hearing for uh HB
1624 that's relative to students with
disabilities participating in
co-curricular activi ities and making an
appropriation thereof and looks like we
have the sponsor
here Welcome to our committee thank you
Mr chair thank you committee members for
uh listening to my testimony on this
bill House Bill 1624 is a retread um
we've had this bill before within this
committee um it is a bipartisan bill you
notice there's not only Republican
members but there are some democrat
members sponsoring this bill including
Miss Mullen and and representative
Moffet and represent
um representative Rock um so uh again
there this bill does a simple thing we
originally this bill stemm from uh
representative uh Moffett over there uh
he had this bill in the F our first term
together in 17 and 18 um the bill passed
the uh committee and ended up with an
inm study recommendation uh in the
second year we studied the bill it came
out as a commission Bill the following
term that bill passed this committee Uh
I chaired that that commission which
looked at the impact of unified
co-curricular activities within school
districts and what the limits were or
what the things were holding back from
districts um executing or providing
unified co-curricular activities if
you're not familiar with uh unified
co-curricular activities these are
activities that um are used both with
special needs students as well as
regular students um and and usually it's
a 50-50 mix most often it's in sports
programs uh you'll see unified soccer
unified basketball but uh there's a
school in New Hampshire doing unified
theater putting on specific uh events
that will cater to some of the special
needs students to put on a program so
it's not limited to Just Sports um this
bill after uh the uh commission last
term I was able to get late Drafting and
we put this bill in it passed this
committee unanimously on a policy basis
it hit finance and I hit a snap
um there were some things that were
missing in the bill that Finance wanted
to see I fixed that in this bill and I
re resubmitted the bill uh it creates a
a $50,000 grant program within the
Department of Education um that $50,000
has a two-tiered purpose the first tier
is if there are applicants school
districts looking to start new unified
uh co-curricular activities um this will
pay for the one-time cost for starting
those programs so I'm going to stick to
sports CU it's the easiest one and I was
a soccer coach in my school district so
I understand it um so if the school
district wanted to start a Unified
co-curricular sports program soccer
program one of the big hurdles is the
initial uh funding of a of uh that sport
so buying uniforms buying the medical
kit for the trainer buying the um soccer
balls those kind of things are a big
one-time upfront expense um and so this
bill looks to offset that expense and
allow people starting to to submit an
application uh requesting the purchase
of just the expense for equipment the
one time um one of the uh I served on
the school board for six years and
served on the budget committee before
that one of the big bait and switches
that they always we always hear about
with uh School boards and and taxpayers
is the state funds at the first time and
then the school districts left with the
ongoing cost going on we made this a
hybrid bill so in other words what I
mean by that is that we're only paying
the equipment costs the schools still
has to commit to the expense of a coach
so they know what they're buying in for
the long-term expenses when they decide
to apply for the grant and get it um and
there's no surprises to the taxpayer so
if they're starting a program and there
a stiping to go to a teacher to coach
that then um that that school dist has
to accept the stien cost as an ongoing
cost but the one-time cost could be
offset by this
[Music]
um again I I this passed this committee
last last and the last session it was on
consent calendar on a on a unanimous
vote and I hope that we'd get similar
support for for this bill again the
policy hasn't changed um I just fix the
problems with the
finances thank you very much
representative Lang uh there are
questions represent bone are you aware
there are some schools I know Bedford is
already doing this and other schools
also so do we really need a bill to to
do it when it's already being done thank
you for that representative B I
appreciate it so again when I chaired
that commission the number one uh reason
we heard for school districts that don't
have programs that are looking to start
programs was tightening budgets was that
one that onetime cost like they might be
fine with paying a teacher $750 stien
but the $4,500 expense to start the
program was a problem um to buy the
medical gear the the uniforms and the
and the sporting gear um the other thing
I meant to say and I apologize there's a
second tier to this program on the on
the on the um grant program and that is
that if the doe has met all the
requirements for new programs the
secondary uh use of those funds would be
to replace equipment in school districts
that already have it so in your case if
they have it and there's money left over
out of the $50,000 we budget annually
then that the school district could say
we need to replace the soccer uniforms
we've had it for the last seven years
and the kids are wearing rags and so
they could apply to replace those Rags
if there's money left over in the grand
program so it supports not only new
programs but potentially ongoing
programs to keep the cost down for the
local taxpayer and keep those programs
my my daughter um actually both my
daughters and my son participated in the
Unified sports program and and I have to
say that those programs are probably the
most uplifting of all the programs that
I attended at the when you go to a
school if you go to unified basketball
Sports the community support and the
student support is amazing um and on
what goes on and we want to encourage
making our children really good human
beings so I I'd encourage this program
thank you uh representative
Tanner thank you Mr chair um I first of
all totally agree it's it's probably the
most uplifting program in in a school um
and it affects uh in a very positive way
both the uh students that are coming
from uh disabilities and and special
education or perhaps having you know
difficulty in some way in school with
the um general population in the school
that I've seen changes on both sides uh
my question is does this uh at all go to
Transportation because I I feel like a
soccer ball and some T-shirts are no big
deal but transportation seems to be one
of the things that keeps these teams
from uh just in housee thank you for
your question and the short answer is no
the short says I didn't do
Transportation costs in this again there
there are certain expenses the school
district needs to accept and that's an
unknown if I have one game it's going to
be$ one amount if I have 10 games it's
going to be a different dollar amount
it's an unknown that uh I don't think I
want to get the Board of Education
involved the Department of Education
involved in trying to figure out funding
for that um and so again this is part of
the I I'm I'm really nervous about bait
and switches right and and we put
together a program we encourag it the
state we fund it for one year and then
the school districts are left hanging
after the second year year and they have
to cancel or do something else because
the funding's up there this is very
clear the labor and the transportation
costs are strictly on a school they need
to know those they'll figure out what
those costs are based on what they
anticipate what the program will look
like and then that's on the local
taxpayer and the school boards to decide
if they want to do that further
questions representa Cornell Thank you
for taking my question this is enabling
for districts that want to start
something like this it's not mandating
that they have to do absolutely not it's
just the grant program the school
district the school district if they
choose they want to put on again I'm
going to stick to sports because it's
the easiest one I I I I know if they
want to do a unified soccer program they
could in the next coming year they can
apply for the grant and then if they get
the grant then they can hire their coach
and do their things if they don't get
the grant they can put it off right
again it's it's just allows the district
to apply for the grant with doe and uh
and see there is if I remember right I
put a sunset clause in here with a
reporting feature got to remember if I
did that or not I know I was yes there
is so again beginning of the fiscal year
2027 and every 5 years thereafter the
department will conduct an efficiency
review of the programs and expenditures
under this paragraph and make
recommendations to the legislator so the
idea was we'll get reporting back if the
$50,000 are being spent are just sitting
there idle and if it's being idle then
let's repeal a statute it's not
needed thank you further
questions yes representative litfield
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative lad for taking my
question I just wanted to ask you um
number one how was the $50,000 how was
that number determined number one and
number two clearly it would depend upon
what type of program is being instituted
I'm just curious how many different
districts do you anticipate this
benefiting sure thank you very much so
so in working with Special Olympics who
were was part of my uh commission that I
did two years ago where I chaired um it
was estimated was about $2,500 expense
per program uh to start if you're
looking at sports because that's what
Special Olympics does is the sports
program so uh was an estimated that
equipment cost was around $2,500 so this
would present 20 possible opportunities
for new programs throughout the
state thank you uh I've got a question
for you um looking at the bill you've
given the authority to make rules on
this to the commissioner or to the
department is that to uh will that also
uh uh develop and end up with the
criteria or the process in which to
award these grants will there be certain
prioritization uh on and handing out the
$50,000 total or is every school going
to get you know a little bit of a chunk
How's that gonna I I don't want to speak
for uh the commissioner on what he plans
on doing but again I'll say this I serve
on ja car as well so I see the rules
that come from Board of Education Direct
Department of Education into into the
into the state and for execution and one
of the things I know is they'll need to
create a form for this to be able to
have the uh depart you know the agencies
file requests for it so again the idea
was to give them broad rulemaking
authority to how they want to administer
this program thank you are there further
questions for the
representative not seeing any thank you
very
much do we have any other pink cards on
this
bill
negative good military speech love that
uh so with that we're going to close
this hearing and we the next hearing
starts at uh
10:30 yeah 10:30 so we have a short
inter room here kind of kind of a point
of order uh Mr chair just wanted to
confirm if uh if as a co-sponsor or
co-sponsor representative Mullen or
myself if if we had we we would not be
able to Pepper a representative Lang
with questions as co-sponsors is that
correct it if if you're going to be
testifying out there you can't come back
and start asking questions we have a
number of bills in which though that
there are many people on on including
some sitting on that committee they can
ask questions you can ask question it's
only if you're going to be out front
testifying and then you come back to the
chair and then you're going to go ask
questions that's uh that's uh not not
what we do thank you m
chair
um
yeah yeah I know that uh let me have a
little chitchat remember what I said the
very beginning of this meeting
so Dave is are F support
this look up last year
see just hang on hang on we're
in the process of discussing
this I know the only difference now is
what represent Lang said the 50
Grand are you guys good we're good good
too yes okay we're going to go ahead and
exec this bill at this
time representa mofet you were one of
the uh sponsors of the bill would you
like to make a motion uh thank you Mr
chair yes I would like to move OTP Oscar
Tango Papa on this measure at this time
representative Mullen would you like
second that thank you very much so we
have a motion on the table to OTP this
uh this bill 1624 made by representative
Moffett and second by representative M
with either with the prime the spon of
the person make the motion have any
discussion or are you good thank Mr I
would simply say that uh this has come
before this committee before and passed
unanimously uh and uh I think
representative Lang did a great job uh
with the commission and chairing the
Commission in making this a bipartisan
measure uh and finance has done its job
and I think it's uh it's been cooked and
is ready to serve repr
Mullen I
concur okay thank you any further
discussion from committee members not
seeing any uh Mr clerk would you please
uh call the rooll or yeah okay the
motion is OTP on HB
FNA uh and representative
cordelli
yes representative
bone representative lakas
yes representative mord says
yes representative
Hobson representative
Ford representative
Nelson representative
sodi representative
litfield
representative uh
BS
for for Myer okay as you as you were
there there's a hand uh represent leus
what is your what is your
question okay we got it we got it we're
we're in the middle of taking this vote
let's continue with the vote please I
representative
luno yes
representative Cornell
yes representative Tanner
yes representative
Ellison
Mullen
yes representative
woodcott
yes representative Porter
yes representative Hall
yes representative
walls
yes representative chairman lad yes
yes so we have 16 to0 for for
OTP is everybody good with consent any
of opposition we're all good it be on
consent thank you very much
representative
Lang you're you're
welcome this was m
m
okay we have uh another bill which we
possibly could take care of here uh that
would be the bill we just heard prior
one and there is an amendment uh I don't
know if everybody's received that
Amendment if you haven't received that
Amendment we really shouldn't take any
action until everybody's had a chance to
read that
Amendment and and we have lots of
opportunity later today to do something
if you haven't read it so I would prefer
if you haven't seen the amendment as to
this point and concur that we wait and
if there's any questions let discuss it
you know on the side here and then and
get it taken care of
today yes Mr chair um I would like to
speak to the amendment because it's just
it's just uh a a little like tweak to
the to the original bill I mean it's no
big deal and I think everybody uh I
passed it out so I think everybody had a
copy of it um I could point I think what
we'll do though representative is that
because we are some are are taking a
break right now let's we we'll do it but
let's you know you you'll be able to
speak to it when we we take this up okay
I think there will be
time
e
okay we have about a couple minutes
before we start with the next bill but
i' communicate this information to the
committee here we will be setting up two
subcommittees so we'll look at bills
here uh one of those bills which we're
going to be looking at uh we haven't
heard yet we will hear hear later on
this afternoon uh that
bill is the the bill that's dealing with
the foundation for the
budget 1680 I
think I wrote this information down and
it's 1680 yeah 1680 I want just to
announce the folks which are going to be
on that
subcommittee I just wrote them down on a
piece of paper and believe it or not I
don't even know where I put the
paper okay good okay on 1680 uh be lad
cordelli
bom luno Porter and
Mullen we will be
meeting uh just so you can put it in
your book uh on the 24th that's a Monday
on that bill at 10 o'clock we should go
about 10 o'clock to
noon then in the afternoon we have a
bill that we will have another
subcommittee on that's hb5 30 that's the
bill that um representative uh Ford
brought forward the other day dealing
with the four-year degrees Etc at the
University level on that on that
committee it will be Ford lad Moffet
leus luno Woodcock Tanner and
Ellison that bill what the subcommittee
work will occur on that at 1:00 on the
same day the 24th so you can get that in
your calendars and be aware of
that
okay thank
you okay we're at 10:30
now okay I would like to move it forward
with our calendar the next uh hearing on
our calendar is
1657 hb1 1657 establishing a New
Hampshire Farm to school reimbursement
program we have the prime sponsor here
uh represent
Simpson welcome to
education thank you for having me and
for hearing our bill this
morning I'm glad to introduce the farm
to school reimbursement program Bill
also called the local food for local
schools reimbursement bill this bill
represents many hours of dedicated time
and energy of stakeholders from across
the state those in agriculture and food
SE sectors those in school nutrition
programs and those community members who
represent the social infrastructure that
makes the local food econom omy Thrive
many of those who contributed to this
bill will be testifying this morning and
we will be able to answer any questions
you have that I may not be able to
answer let me provide a little
background the farm to school program
nourishes children supports local
farmers and economies and strengthens
the resil resiliency of our supply chain
some schools and communities already
participate in the New Hampshire Farm to
school program and experience these
positive
results the investment we are asking the
state legislature to make will make it
possible for schools and communities all
over the state to take advantage of the
benefit of local food for local
schools with this policy we can improve
the health and well-being of our
children and the resiliency of our local
food system the department of
education's office of nutrition programs
and services would provide a monetary
incentive to schools who choose to
direct more of their per meal cash
reimbursement funds from the USDA
towards purchases from New Hampshire and
New England
Farmers the state would encourage this
channeling of federal funds into the
local economy by awarding schools a
dollar for every $3 spent on food from
New Hampshire and a dollar for every $6
spent on food from the New England
region the goal is for our local schools
to be purchasing at least 10% of their
food from local farms
across the
state by offering every school a
reimbursement up to $1,200 we would be
investing in our children's health by
redirecting 1.2 million federal dollars
into our local economy we ensure that we
build Food Systems infrastructure that
will make us resilient for the future
our children's health and the health of
our farms and farming communities are
worth the investment from the state a
robust Farm to school program will help
strengthen New Hampshire's agricultural
sector and Regional food security it
will also help New Hampshire students
understand the regional agricultural
Geographic social and cultural aspects
of our food system in New
Hampshire before I hand it over to
representative Murray who will talk
more I I'm wondering if it would be okay
my school nutrition services director
has asked me to read her one page of
testimony she um is having a Staffing
shortage and was not able to be here but
she's been involved in farm to school
work we started the adventure together
over 10 years ago and she wanted me to
read this if that's all
right it is
yeah thank you I appreciate
that her name is Jean
Pierce hello thank you for your time and
for allowing my statement to be read in
my
absence my name is Jean Pierce and I'm
currently the director of school
nutrition for the exitor region
Cooperative school district and the
exitor school district I have served as
two-time past president of the New
Hampshire school nutrition Association
past committee chair of public policy
legislation for New Hampshire school
nutrition Association and I have served
other organizations both at a national
level and within our state to support
our children's needs within the school
nutrition
environment I'm thrilled to support hb1
1657 FNA the farm to school
reimbursement program I understand many
schools are currently making purchases
from local farmers but we are in direct
competition with the retail sales which
hinders our ability to increase the
amount we would like to purchase or for
some schools to make any purchases
currently as I have in the past I do
make purchases from local farmers
vendors within New Hampshire and other
New England states beef fish fruit maple
syrup vegetables to name a few the
positive effects of this bill will allow
schools to purchase more local Goods
within our region help our local farmers
and increase the relationships within
the community this bill would also allow
many educational moments for our
students to understand the importance of
where our food comes from how far it may
travel and the direct impact it does
have on the environment and economy this
is such a
positive I speak for myself that our
current supply chain issue show how
important purchasing local is to having
a food supply for my schools I have
spent hours looking for items that are
grown processed and produced in our area
schools across New Hampshire have been
working hard to develop relationships
with farmers and to learn and understand
how we both are able to support and
educate our community on the importance
of purchasing local Goods this bill will
help in ways that will only be seen
after it is passed and working in our
state when funding stays local it grows
the economy supports our community and
shows how important keeping our local
farms grow growing is to maintain a food
source for all citizens within our state
thank you for your time Gan
Pierce and now I'm happy to answer any
questions that you have
yeah thank you chairman good morning
thank you for uh taking my question and
being here today and bring this program
uh to us just a couple questions uh
organizationally how do local farms uh
get to participate in this
sure so I'm sorry I keep going back
forth to see
you uh you know it's very local specific
across the state there um different
schools operate in different ways but um
often times community members are also
involved in connecting schools and
farmer it's very much in a lot of
regions it's very much um there are food
hubs that help with that sometimes Farms
just uh will connect because they do a
farmers market at a school or near a
school it's very different but I know um
I haven't seen her yet but Stacy purlo
there she is Stacy Perlo who runs the
farm to school program is also to hear a
here to answer any questions that are
more technical or if you'd like more
information about that you just want to
follow up thank you is the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau involved in this um we have
spoken with them but there he is hi
uh Rob Johnson is here in the back from
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau thank you
I'm sure he'd be happy to answer any
questions you have for him as
well hello hi Simpson nice to see you
and meet you and thank you for coming um
I just have a I think this is a great
idea um I was just curious if you could
describe the
600,000 um cost next year what what that
entails definitely so the
um as I said a lot of the stakeholders
have been working on this for a few
years and based also in some of the
research that's been done about um
resilience food system resiliency in New
England and in New Hampshire there's a
goal of having um I would say we all
have a goal of like 10% of the money
that we spend on food in local schools
would be spent locally so that instead
of those the $1.2 million that comes in
from the federal government if we could
instead of sending that outside of New
Hampshire send that into New Hampshire
we could build up our own resiliency
right and so if the state invests
$600,000 $40,000 of which would be the
um technology infrastructure that would
have to support the program and 560,000
plus that 1.2 million that's 10% of the
money that we spend in New Hampshire on
local um
food
yeah yeah I'm trying to understand um I
guess why this is needed cannot the
schools already buy local Goods if they
want to using the federal money do the
local Goods cost more or why are they
not currently doing that because I know
we have lots of really good you know
farms and produce and all kinds of stuff
in the state why are schools not doing
that
now I just I don't understand some
schools are doing it um and some schools
are not and so this is an incentive for
schools who are not doing it to
participate but it's also just a little
bit and I think Jean mentioned this in
her testimony um it's also just a little
bit of money that's extra for the budget
for school nutrition so school
nutritionists will tell you that they
operate in a very narrow narrow budget
and that when they um have even a little
bit more to operate then they are able
to access local food more so often times
um there are some products that are the
same price um and there are some
products that are um cheaper if you buy
them elsewhere but it's more it's better
for the students and better for the
economy to buy them from here so having
that little $1,200 kind of makes a big
difference in some schools especially
smaller
schools further questions representative
Tanner uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh representative Simpson for coming
with this this great idea um this was
something that you know I'm ancient so a
long time ago we tried to do this at our
school
and um the big push back was not the
Farms not the money but the retail
Distributors who can distribute for
example
Tomatoes uh 247 360 days a year because
they get them from all over whereas the
local farmers um could give us quite a
deal in August uh with the Tomato crops
that were coming in even even local
people you know the farmers market the
little Farmers Market thing in the in
the common um and at that time the
distributor really told our food service
uh manager that if she were to buy the
tomatoes from local Distributors um he
was not going to distribute fruits and
vegetables to her
anymore uh the and that's kind of the
hammer that that I think the retail uh
areas have and I'm just wondering I
noticed that um your food service person
in her testimony that you read mentioned
just briefly mentioned about the
Distributors and I was wondering if how
much of a roadblock that still is and uh
maybe how you're thinking about uh
dealing with that thank you um sure so
I'm not sure when that was how long ago
that was but I do know in the past 10
years the um Local Food Systems
infrastructure has really improved and I
think you're going to hear from someone
from one of our food hubs in one of the
regions of the State who will be able to
speak more probably to that question but
um kind of big picture I I do want to
say that it really it is different now
than it has ever been in that school
some schools are already working
together to have a larger to have larger
buying power when they approach um
suppliers and Distributors so um and
they have often the backing of folks in
their Community who can also help them
um navigate some of that that but I'd
like for others who are working in that
process to answer that question more
specifically
yeah represent Moffett thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here uh we
got a a good number of emails on this
which they looked at last night so
there's some real enthusiasm and I'm
sensing great energy for this and uh I
just noticed the analysis it it
establishes a uh Farm to school
reimburse reimbursement program so it
establishes a program and I see the the
$600,000 note um I'm trying to
understand is this a a permanent program
that Doe will somehow be in involved
with can you explain permanent or or is
this a permanent program or sure let me
talk about that for a little bit um so I
did notice in the fiscal note that um
when we we've spoken with Folks at
nutrition services and the Department of
Education and they did not indicate to
us that they would need extra staff
people to um administer this program so
I was a little surprised when I saw that
in the fisical note that it talked about
that but um it
would I mean if it succeeds I would hope
it would be permanent yeah for sure um
but right now it's uh the 600,000 for
one
year thank you so answer your question
so so I understand this to be a oneyear
general fund initiative not a permanent
program
correct I that's a good
question
um I'm trying to find the
bill I don't I'll be honest with you I
don't think it would be worth the
investment in the technology as much if
it were just a one-year program um so I
think the intention especially back to
the distributor and supplier issue the
intention is that by focusing money in
the local economy we would also allow
communities like in real life who are
trying to get food from farms to schools
to be able to set up the social networks
that make that happen right and so once
those networks are up it would be nice
to keep them going um if the if the
incentive works for a year that's great
I think we just address it again again
in a year if if everybody thinks it's
going well and we rah rah um there is a
lot of energy behind it right I think
we'd address it again in a year and see
if we want to make it permanent but it
doesn't I don't think it's in the bill
that it be
permanent thank thank you that's a
really I think to me that's a crucial
question
yeah okay I I have a question for you
and then we'll move on to other people
might speak on this bill I come from a
farming community havil it's up in the
Connecticut River much of the land in
havil is now owned by farmers in
Vermont um the tier one is uh for foods
that originate in New Hampshire yes um
crops which are grown in New Hampshire
but then processed across the river in
Vermont and some of it's vice versa too
we consider ourselves up there one
region right and and and uh we have uh
many dairies in this state that are
Co-op or milk has gone out to New York
or Massachusetts Etc and then comes back
by a company out there and then we have
hatchland dairy in my particular
Community where everything is done right
there produced bottled drunk in New
Hampshire and of course they sell
outside to Massachusetts and Vermont as
well so I guess the question I have here
here is that um is um the milk that goes
out of state is that and comes back in
through a uh organization that's owned
and Corporation that's owned elsewhere
is that going to get this benefit or is
a person like Howard hatch who has
hatchin dairy in hail going to get the
benefit the priority will be to food
that is Gran and um Dairy Etc produced
in New Hampshire to be um used in New
Hampshire so that's the priority is
local the local food to the
local schools so I I I guess and
followup the origin of the food would
have been New
Hampshire but it's going outside the
state and then coming back in the form
of hood or whomever my booth Brothers
whatever and so is that going to count
as a tier one or is that going to be a
tier
two so representative lad chairman I I
will give you my opinion I think that
that will be worked out in the rules in
the rul making I don't think that's in
the bill I think that will have to be
hashed out in the details of rule making
am I wrong about that well I'm I'm just
a little confused and I've talked to
folks over there at the Department of
Agriculture and marketing here in the
state and there's there there are
concerns regarding this
this uh area that I I'm I'm discussing
sure I think that's definitely the thing
that's going to have to be worked
through the most time will have to be
spent working through that my my
envisioning or My Hope Is that we would
pass the bill and then as in rule making
bring all the stakeholders together or
maybe I mean you all could do that in a
subcommittee maybe as well but that we
would bring all the stakeholders
together um and submit comments for rule
making you know go through the whole rul
making process and that that's where
that would be kind of hashed out okay
thank you but I but I'd definitely thank
you for raising it yeah we have other
folks that want to speak here we have a
whole lot of cards so uh thank you very
much for presenting the bill uh the next
person will
be thank you for having me thank you
very much representa
Murray
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Megan Murray I represent the
town of Amherst Hillsboro District
22 I'm actually coming from a different
perspective on this bill I'm not here
really to talk about the larger part of
the structure of the bill I'm talking
about this from an educational
perspective and a parent sort of
perspective as well on behalf of my
community um so the bill presents
present enormous opportunities to
connect Learners teachers and families
and communities to the agricultural
Community nothing in this bill mandates
or directs the Department of Education
districts or schools to implement any
specific criteria or assessment around
food education but what the bill does do
is serve as a jumping off point for New
Hampshire educational communities to
make real world inquiry based
connections and explorations to the
local food system and communities in
which students live
increasing the amount of locally sourced
nutritional food on a child's lunch tray
serves as an opportunity to begin
talking about farming practices
Agricultural Science Nutrition geography
and regionality of where our food comes
from and the importance of it though as
I said there is nothing prescriptive
about what the teaching Community must
Implement here I do believe that our
state has the opportunity to integrate
learning that provides real world
scenarios to meet educational goals and
standards the educ ational goals and
standards of Learners today farming is
no longer a process of just tilling the
ground sewing seeds and then harvesting
a crop though that is the basic tenant
farming touches all sorts of topics like
climate resiliency aquaculture
Hydroponics and many other
state-of-the-art growing practices that
require a high degree of Science
Education behind them I truly see the
natural connection learning communities
can make while simultaneously supporting
nutrient dense sourcing of foods locally
and regionally New Hampshire has an
entire network of small farms and
producers throughout the state the
farming Community is vital to New
Hampshire's food sourcing infrastructure
and we have seen that a well-
diversified food infrastructure is vital
to a healthy food economy in New
Hampshire there is no more appropriate
time to implement such an incentive as
now other Regional states have also done
so within the last calendar year Vermont
being one of the most recent that I'm
aware of though New York and Montana I
believe have implemented it as
well
as a parent this excites me because food
is such a vital component of who we are
in our families towns and in our
communities to know that a child might
come home and say I tried a new
vegetable today I had K Robie um did you
know that that only came four miles away
from where we are that's exciting um I
urge the passage of HB 1657 to support
the need for strong local food sourcing
initiatives within School communities
and I thank you and I'll take any
question thank you very much are there
questions for the
representative not seeing thank you very
much oh yes representative Ford thank
you Mr chair and thank you for offering
the opportunity to ask you a question
sure I wonder if in
your uh endeav it this way looking at
from education you've explored or
considered the opportunity for pathway
type programs through the high schools
to segue into the community colleges or
whatever to get into this marketing
growthing knowledge of and therefore
create career paths for people that they
might not otherwise have considered
thank you for the question I think
that's an excellent point I think that
it's a really interesting um opportunity
and as I said I think these are natural
um connections that might be made by
districts and schools and even within
the department if that is under their
purview but um I'm not here to mandate
that within the bill that's not the
nature of this bill but I see your point
Thank you you're welcome thank you very
much for your testimony thank you you're
welcome represent
McGee thank you good morning chairman
lad and members of the education
committee uh I'm representative cat
McGee and I represent Hillsboro 27 which
is Hollis a farming Comm
Community um as you've heard from the
prior uh sponsors who've testified on
hb1
1657 there are many people here today
with a great deal of experience in the
practice of implementing a farm to
school reimbursement
program when I learned of this bill I
wanted to sign on for another benefit I
see in New Hampshire passing this bill
into
law it's a way of acknowledging our
local Growers who uh always rise to
being involved in their community
Hollis was established in
1746 and has signs posted on both of the
state roads leading into our town center
that say welcome to Hollis an active
farming
Community it's a dee rooted part of our
heritage and our identity much like our
excellent schools so I wanted to be here
today and I wanted to help sponsor this
bill to say just a little bit about how
important it is to acknowledge that this
Farm to school program does more than
bring local produce into our schools
it says we value the importance of New
Hampshire's Rich farming tradition it
says that resiliency of our communities
is steeped in how we use local resources
and how we work together for the greater
good I know the owners of two of our
major Farms David or of L farms and and
Rick Hardy of Brookdale Fruit Farm
farmer Dave as he's known attended UNH
Co-op and came away with such an
enthusiasm for farming as a Young Man
that he convinced the owner of L Farm
who had no interest in continuing in the
family business to lease the lands and
sell the building that make up his
successful business uh several decades
later but he has admitted to me that the
family farming model is running up
against a lot of modern obstacles in
recent years and he's had to continually
innovate in order to keep um people
stopping by his farm store as opposed to
shopping at a One-Stop shop like
hanford's just down the street Rick
Hardy on the other hand of
Brookdale uh is a Seventh Generation
farmer in Hollis and Beyond these two
men and their very different stories of
coming to toil the land Hollis is also
home to lvo Sullivans and just over one
of our borders Kimble
Farm like many other sectors of our
economy family farming faces intense
pressures in a modern
world making the margins to stay in the
business of farming as a smallscale
grower gets trickier by the year whether
farmers are facing big box competitors
and their endless produce as others have
testified to already costly changes in
farming practices and Regulatory burdens
or unpredictable crop patterns patterns
a little tricky to say crop patterns uh
of drought Deluge or pests we should all
be grateful for their commitment to keep
the tradition of of our agricultural
Heritage in our communities and we
should view H1
1657 as the kind of partnership that
brings resiliency to our schools our
communities and to local
agriculture the kind of resiliency we
should want to support although the
annual cap of 1,200 per school is not a
huge amount of money it is the act of
generating the partnership and expanding
local connections that strengthens our
communities I'm very in favor of this
legislation adopting a farm to school
program in the state of New Hampshire
and I ask that you consider sending the
bill to the Full House with a a
committee vote of a to pass thank you
and I'm happy to answer any questions
although I'm not sure I'm the right
person to answer some of the detailed
questions you may have thank you
representative yes we do have some
people that have those details behind
you are there any questions for the
representative not seeing any thank you
very much have a good day I'd like to
invite Carl Johnson from
Monroe just up the Valley from
heril Good Morning the center of the
earth I'm uh Carl Johnson I'm the board
president of the Northeast organic
Farmers Association of New Hampshire NOA
New Hampshire is a nonprofit
organization devoted to supporting and
promoting organic farming in the
state and thank you for for allowing me
to speak
today New Hampshire Farms both organic
and conventional are struggling to stay
in business when we most need them at a
time when climate change and economic
uncertainty suggest that we should be
increasing Local Foods uh production New
Hampshire farmers are fighting to for
their lives to against large scale us
farms and even Farms Halfway Around the
World they need our help to stay
afloat at the same time New Hampshire
schools are struggling to afford fresh
and nutritious meals for our
children recent shortages have impacted
School District's ability to purchase
fresh produce items I can tell you my
grandchild great great-grandchildren
often come home from school with uneaten
school supplied nutritionally lacking
snacks in their backpacks they just they
want to eat them and and to be honest
I'm not sure I want them to eat them uh
Farm to school presents an opportunity
for us to help solve both
problems selling to schools is a major
market for local
farmers it provides them the potential
for significant new
Revenue Farm to school lets Farmers tap
into a stable Revenue stream that is
most active during a typical typically
lean time for
Farmers Financial stability is essential
for keeping New Hampshire Farmers
farming and keeping their land safe from
development Farm to school also
strengthens the local
economy by supporting local farmers
schools help keep dollars in the
community and purchasing New Hampshire
products contributes to our tax base
which in turn funds our Public Schools
finally the farm to school program helps
students learn why local food is good
for health the environment and the
economy I urge you to support this
valuable
legislation thank you thank you very
much for your presentation are there any
questions not seeing hands thank you
very much thank
you
Maria
Perez oh represent oh District uh 23
yes good morning good morning Mr Sharon
thank you everyone for the opportunity
to speak up in suppor HB
1657 as someone who grew up in a farm
environment I learned in the early how
to grow vegetables how to um be grateful
to have the opportunity to see how hard
it is to grow those vegetables and then
appreciate all the hardware that comes
to when you enjoy the vegetables and and
you you enjoy uh food from the Farms I'm
here to support this bill because in my
uh District um um I represent District
23 in Milford we have a lot of farms and
we already have some programs that um
some restaurants already use and uh from
the farm to the table and is helping uh
F local farms uh with uh providing
vegetables and and nutritional things uh
to for our um community so I believe
this uh bill would a help not just to
provide that uh and the economy
incentive for a local farms to continue
doing what they doing but the schools to
bring better nutrition
uh uh products to school system and that
that can help with uh the kids to uh
have a better nutrition uh food in the
table so I I I'm here just to support
the bill because I believe this is
something that we need and then when it
comes to education I see I see the
potential to be helping especially now
that we try to get kids to learn um
skills not just um going to University
and college but a trade you know we have
a lot of Trades that we can utilize if
we pass some of these bills especially
uh HB uh 1657 thank you so much for your
time thank you very much representative
any
questions represent M thank you Mr chair
and thank you uh represent Perez for
being here and I want to personalize
this a little bit and this is a question
uh I thought I just thought of and and I
hope everybody else will listen to this
question and um I want to reference asle
um our newest representative
representative Hall uh and here's my
question and it relates to uh towns that
live on borders and uh representative
Hall actually comes from a farming
family living right on the Connecticut
River and the reason I mentioned this is
uh the the Peasley Farm uh was just
across basically across River from a
representative Halls farm and so our
High School uh growon High School uh Is
On The Border there's a lot of
communities On the Border uh
representative lad the chairs
so my concern and my question suddenly
is uh this bill is New Hampshire
specific and a community like Hollis or
Milford Milford is fairly right in the
middle of the state so so to speak it's
not on the border so my concern and I I
don't know that you can answer this but
I want to put this out there is if an
existing or current a school that
currently has
relationships um with farms uh just
across the river uh that that provide
great produce and great
support uh If This Were to pass would
this preclude uh gron High School from
buying uh potatoes from the Peasley Farm
just across the river in Vermont so
that's my question for you and I hope
I'm sure others could hear it as well
yeah to be honest this bill to me is not
we not try to hurt um Farms that already
doing that with with the school systems
what we what I see from this bill is
growing more opportunities especially
helping the economy uh we see it uh
during the pandemic a lot of the farms
you know the last past two years that uh
a lot of the Farms they they help local
um schools by providing some of the
vegetables apples and things that they
had and I think we're not trying from
what I'm seeing and and I I can be wrong
but from what I'm seeing is we're not
we're not trying to take that away from
the Farms already doing but we we wanted
to see growing we want to see more Farms
we want to see more products come into
our school systems and then be more
flexible and more available for the
schools to to get
them thank you thank you very much
representative perz are there further
questions thank you for your testimony
today thank you oh you had a question um
can I I just add one thing before I um
yes May so one of the things I said you
know at the beginning I grow up uh uh in
a farm environment one of the things
that even though that I moved here 35
years ago from El Salvador I go to local
farms just to continue learning the have
it of how hard the people in the farm
industry work to put the Bas of us on
our tabl and just to continue that
gratefulness of the people that they
work in in the farm system thank you so
much thank
you is Chris phoh
here welcome
Chris and a reminder to anybody that's
testifying if you have written uh
testimony it will certainly help the
clerk here uh not having to take a lot
of long hand short hand whatever
and right right right if we just could
attach what you have that makes it much
easier for representative mfet go ahead
Chris thank you my name is Chris farell
I'm the vice president of Business
Development for fresh pix Cafe Fresh
piic Cafe is the largest operator of
school nutrition programs in New
Hampshire providing service to more than
37,000 students in 41 New Hampshire
school districts as part of Cafe
Services based in Manchester New
Hampshire we are one of the largest 30
largest Food Service management
companies in the country I'm here to
express Fresh Pick Cafe's support for
House Bill
1657 many states throughout the country
have recently adopted or in the process
of adopting Farm toch School
reimbursement programs House Bill 1657
stands out among these for its clear
Common Sense approach to the program
with its clear-cut requirements for
qualifying documenting and reimbursing
for Local Foods the New Hampshire Farm
to school reimbursement program avoids
the pitfalls of convoluted guidel lines
and complex reporting structures that
can be found in some other states
programs the Simplicity of this program
ensures it its success in achieving the
goals of supporting and promoting local
Agriculture and exposing students to
Local Foods over the past 20 years fresh
Pi Cafe has executed numerous local food
promotions and menus facilitated meet
your farmer lunch and dinner events and
purchased directly from farms farm
cooperatives and local food aggregators
we have engaged in these activities
because we understand that introducing
students to Local Foods farms and food
producers is an important part of their
educational experience and help connect
them to their communities these
activities meet students where they
where they are acknowledging their
generation's interest in sustainability
and environmental awareness House Bill
1657 will incentivize and enable New
Hampshire school districts to further
expand on these types of activities it
will support and promote local food
Growers and producers and by increasing
demand this program will incentivize
Food Distributors to offer more local
products improving access for all
institutional retail food service
operations most importantly it'll enrich
and enhance the school dining experience
of New Hampshire students and increase
their appreciation of all that New
Hampshire has to offer thank you very
much thank you are there any
questions not seeing any thank you very
much for coming
today
Stacy
persell PS l w is that correct that's
correct thank
you good morning everybody thank you um
so my name is Stacy purlo I coordinate
the New Hampshire Farm to school program
and work out of unh's sustainability
Institute I'm not here to take a
position on the bill but to provide some
information about Farm to school and
farm to school in New
Hampshire Farm to school enriches the
connection communities have with fresh
healthy food and local food producers by
changing food purchasing and education
practices at schools in early care and
education sites Farm to school Works in
three areas procurement local foods are
purchased promoted and served in the
cafeteria as a snack or in a classroom
taste test education students
participation participate in education
activities related to agriculture food
health and nutrition School Gardens
students engage in Hands-On experiential
learning through
gardening Farm school programs exist in
every state and are connected through
the national Farm to school network the
USDA also has a farm to school program
in their office of Community Food
Systems it is also home to the farm to
school grant program which over the
years since its Inception has brought
half a million dollars to support
various Farm to school programs around
the
state New Hampshire Farm to school Works
closely with the northeast regional
office of the USDA and their Farm to
school staff
person New Hampshire Farm to school also
participates in the Northeast Farm to
school collaborative where we share and
learn together and collaborate on
projects across the
region here in New Hampshire we also
have a New Hampshire school New Garden
Network made up of partner organizations
like UNH Cooperative Extension NOA New
Hampshire strawberry bank and Portsmouth
cornicopia project in the conval school
district us fish and wildlife New
Hampshire egg in the classroom and
others the pharmac school network and
the school garden Network currently
collaborated on developing a
professional development webinar series
for educators that begins next week that
will cover such topics as local food
procurement composting in schools
Hydroponics garden and classroom
connections and
more every few years the USDA collects
Farm to school census data from schools
across the country the last census was
done in
2019 in New Hampshire 41 School food
authorities responded representing 172
schools and almost 67,000 students 26
sfas said they were serving local food
in schools and the local food was being
served in the national school lunch
program the school breakfast program and
the fresh fruit and veget vegetable
program as well as summer programs 19
sfas have edible School Gardens but I
know there are more because I've done
some my own survey work um and there are
more than a 100 edible School Gardens
across the
state the top Local Foods schools are
purchasing are apples lettuce tomatoes
squash cucumbers carrots and
potatoes data collected by New Hampshire
Farm to school says half the schools are
buying directly from a farm and other
half are purchasing Local Foods through
a food Hub or a
distributor in total total schools are
spending less than $900,000 on local
food
purchases so that was a quick overview
of hara school and I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you very much are
there any questions yes represent
Woodcock thank you represent good
morning just a I want to heard your
statistic correctly you said 172 schools
are surveyed but only 26 in the state of
participating is that correct so this is
a based on a USDA survey so only um 41
School food authorities responded to the
survey so that certainly not all of the
school districts so of the 41 that
responded um 26 said they were serving
local food in
schools thank you thank you represent
you're welcome further questions yes
represent cordelli thank you uh thank
you for being here uh you mentioned uh
Farm to school grants could you expand
on that a little bit
sure so the USDA started a farm to
school Brant grant program in
2013 um and so uh lots of entities are
eligible to apply schools Farms
nonprofits um businesses anybody that
wants to support a farm to school
program um and so since that grant
program was
established um we've had numerous grants
come into the state um totaling about
half a million dollars um and so the
grants were just due on Monday was the
deadline for this year's Farm to school
grants so we've had four proposals go in
um three from New Hampshire and then one
is a multi-state
proposal thank you very much are there
any for yes representative
Richfield thank you chairman lad and
thank you for taking my question a
couple of questions that I have is if
I'm hearing you correct correctly the
USDA already has some Grant programs
that are out there that are not
necessarily being taken advantage of um
am I hearing you correctly well they
have a farm to school grant program and
the money is not to be used for the
purchase of food that's not what the
program is for it's for program
activities to help support developing a
plan of how you're going to purchase
food of developing curriculum school
garden
programs um so it's it's the supportive
activities it's not for the purchase of
food Mr chair follow
um May I follow up with two questions
okay um the next one is do you happen to
know what the average Grant is per
school or nonprofit um I would so
they've just changed it so there are two
tiers of Grant programs there's a
planning Grant which is up to $50,000 in
one year and then there's a
implementation Grant uh which is a
two-year Grant and they' just changed it
to be up to $500,000 it used to be at
$100,000 and we've had several entities
in the state receive
$100,000 um Nash School District Summers
School District Portsmouth School
District um uh and then this this year
they just changed that amount so it's up
to $500,000 for a two-year
implementation Grant so go ahead um my
question is and and hopefully you're the
right person to ask ask but in in
listening to this just my interpretation
has been basically the schools maybe
cannot afford this local fresh food
right the Farmers can't necessarily
afford um to sell the schools at the
lower prices and we're looking to bridge
this Gap um it looks to me as though the
bill is saying
$600,000 which is a lot of money in a
state budget but yet it looks to me as
though when it's broken down per
District it would be
$1,200 I am I'm wondering does $1,200
even make a significant difference as
far as the food is concerned so it's
$1,200 per school so not school district
per school so a large school district
like Manchester that would has like 18
schools it's $1,200 per School per
school okay um and it can make a
significant difference um I mean school
lunch funding is is difficult to to work
with um to put a meal on a plate for
maximum of a130
um is hard um and so and a lot of
schools food service programs run in the
red um meaning they're losing
money um so this would help their
programs
um and of course helped our farming
Community Mr chair May the last one I
promise that's the last question last
question okay um I just want to clarify
when you said the maximum of the dollar3
I thought the federal reimburse was
typically around $3 and $4 but it also
has to cover labor a $3 reimbursement is
uh not just for food it's for labor and
other requirements of a school Food
Service program like napkins or Forks um
so the national figure is that 45 you
know 45 cents for every dollar gets
spent on
food um but yeah so a $3 reimbursement
per meal it's got to cover labor and
food and all the
other expenses related to school food
service thank you uh any further
questions and we have our last uh
present pardon
me uh I don't see the commissioner I
Jasper's not here but uh you're talking
about Marketing in
agriculture and we also have M McKenzie
snow here from the Department nut with
the nutrition person so that's
doe yeah this is probably more
appropriate this is probably more an
appropriate witness then for my question
if I could ask one more one question of
this witness please just go ahead thank
you um so one of the things that we
heard in the earlier testimony is that
we have a lot of for Farms on the border
and this bill sets up two tiers it sets
up tier one for New Hampshire farms and
Tier Two For the Rest of New England and
I'm wondering if it makes sense to
expand the definition of tier one to New
Hampshire Farms or anything within 25
miles of the New Hampshire border um to
accommodate the fact that we've got all
these border Farms that really should be
a supplying the Border schools and I'm
wondering if that works from your point
of
view it works for my point of view if
you know if this bill passes we'll
certainly certainly consider that thank
you very much because we do have this
school districts that go on both sides
of the Border yes I know yeah and we we
have uh yeah a number of states where
fact in my community if you're an AB
budding Community to havil even if
you're on the other side of the river
you get to bid on jobs at the same level
that local bids are given out so we
consider that area as one region one
Community fact our school buses go B
both sides the r River so okay we have
one thank you very much for your
presentation to uh we have Jessica gor
uh from the New Hampshire hunger
Solutions welcome Jessica hi
welcome good morning Representatives my
name is Jessica Goran I'm the deputy
director of New Hampshire hunger
Solutions our organization Advocates
Advocates to end food in security
improve access to nutritious nutritious
food and address hunger's root cause
issues
for all New Hampshire residents New
Hampshire hunger Solutions is committed
to improving participation in school
meals with a focus on School breakfast
I'm here today to speak in support of
hb65
1657 establishing a New Hampshire Farm
to school reimbursement program New
Hampshire hunger Solutions has surveyed
over 100 New Hampshire parents and over
200 students to find out their opinions
on School meals students were most
excited about meal options that
contained fresh fruits and vegetables
like smoothies parfaits and smoothie
bowls parents said the things that they
would like most to change would be
healthier meal options including fresh
fruits and vegetables the farm to school
program would provide students with
nutritious local Farm Fresh Foods and
would encourage School Meal
participation increased meal
participation leads to healthier
students who are able to learn this
leads to higher test scores increased
graduation rates and Improv short-term
and long-term economic outcomes in the
short term increased participation helps
to increase revenues for food service
departments which often have their own
funding and revenue streams separate
from school districts purchases from Lo
local farms will also have a positive
impact on local economies and support
local farmers and food
producers in the long-term higher
graduation rates lead to higher rates of
post of I'm sorry uh higher graduation
rates lead to higher rates of pay
postgraduation farmers do better better
students are healthier and do better
local economies improve it's a win for
New
Hampshire thank thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you this takes
us through all our pink cards we have
here we do have of course from the
Department McKenzie snow uh if anybody
on the committee has a question uh we
can take a couple minutes for that
um she's available do you have a
question um McKenzie do you have an a
moment you could come up to the
table represent cordellia you have a
question yes thank you thank you for uh
being here um and did you did you want
to introduce who you have at the table
with you absolutely thank you and thank
you for the opportunity to do so um for
the record I'm Mackenzie snow I'm a
division director of learner support at
the New Hampshire Department of
Education and I'm very excited to
introduce our new administrator of the
office of nutrition programs and
services Mackenzie can you get the mic a
little closer to you I can can you hear
me better now that's much better I'm
sorry thank you um so just again quickly
uh I'm McKenzie snow I'm division
director of learner support at the New
Hampshire Department of Education and
I'm very excited to also introduce you
to Kelly Rambo who is our new
administrator of the office of food and
nutrition programs she actually comes to
us from palum school district where she
was a um School District uh nutrition
and wellness
director thank you uh are there any
specific questions for the department at
this time yes yes represent cordelli
thank you um I had questions about the
uh the fiscal note and uh the funding um
the uh bill specifies um 600,00
for the
2023 uh year um and it specifies on page
two that 40,000 of that is for um
Information Systems
use uh and set up um but uh there's also
an indication of staffing needs in um
the area of
$180,000 for 2023 and Beyond um would
that be uh in addition to the
$600,000 so the the real cost is more uh
in the area of $780,000
that's correct representative so we we
um anticipate a significant need to
accommodate for new transactions in our
food nutrition um information technology
system which is funded at $40,000 but to
ensure that we are able to provide appr
at technical assistance and training to
the field monitoring the field to
develop um new processes and procedures
for the submission of reimbursements the
verification of that the provision of
reimbursements um for verifying the
place of origin we do anticipate that
two new full-time staff would be
required thank you yes followup yes um
yes I was wondering also
if we've had some discussion about the
tiers
and um you know where the farm is
located and who it's owned by and so
forth do you see problems in the current
bill with the Department ter
determining um who qualifies for what
kind of reimbursement so our
understanding is that the place of
origin is uh via self attestation um
that would be something that would be
included in our monitoring it is not
something that the department has done
or has experienced doing and would
require significant staff capacity to be
able to take up that
responsibility thank you further
questions of the department yes uh
representative Ford and then represent
B thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming for questions um the question
I have is with increasing numbers of
students getting shall we say their only
or their primary food at the school
through the school's lunch program what
do you see as this kind of thing what
kind of impact do you you see having on
addressing this problem having on
addressing uh that need and which may
continue
unfortunately so if I understand the
question correctly um this is limited to
those current participants in the
national school lunch program so it is
not so much expanding access to um
School provided lunches but uh incenting
uh and reimbursing for those locally
sourced vendors but it might then
thereby have an improvement of the
quality that they're able to offer
because they can access fresh vegetables
and so forth uh as part of this program
potentially thank you represent B thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking the
question
um mentioned before about USDA grants is
there any way the state can apply for
those grants at the state level to do
this program so we currently participate
in the national school lunch program um
and that's what was referenced earlier
that uh this uh new program proposed in
the bill uh would be limited to those
participants in a uh reimbursement or
grant program in which we uh currently
participate thank you very much are
there any further questions not seeing
thank you very much thank you if and if
I just may I want to draw attention to
one additional piece do you mind
chairman quickly quickly um so in
addition to the new staff I just want to
draw attention to the feasibility of the
implementation timeline so it says
summer of 2022 it would take um that
implementation timeline is unfeasible uh
in order for us to recruit higher and uh
Ru out a new program so thank you for
your consideration of that important
piece of technical assistance thank you
not seeing any more people uh that have
submitted cards we're going to close
this
hearing
we're going to go right directly into
the next hearing scheduled prior to
lunch here um we're looking now at HB
1655 relative to natural immunity system
health and wellness curriculum in
schools
okay I have no cards we we need to have
pink card
on on this
bill the
sponsor I did not do I need to as a
sponsor yeah I'm
sorry the dog dog that
qualifies it's very
important right along at agriculture
right that bill has a lot of questions a
lot of
questions is it one year I don't know if
it's permanent or not and how does the
department hire hire
someone
go ahead tell her it's so
funny
and and then answer
question
okay we're ready to go ahead with this
hearing
now
representative y yep representative
Foster welcome thank you Mr
chairman I'm here today to introduce
House Bill one uh 1655 a bill relative
to the natural immunity system health
and wellness curriculum in schools could
you excuse me for a sec could you put
that mic right up the uh so we can hear
you usually people can because I'm hard
of hearing so I speak loud usually so
okay wait AE
excuse me those in the back of the room
if you want to take your conversation in
the hallway you're more than welcome to
do so but we're trying to go ahead
here thank you go ahead thank you six uh
House Bill 1655 seeks to ensure that all
New Hampshire students shall learn how
to strengthen and maintain their body's
immune systems through diet nutrition
vitamins dietary supplements and
physical activities as a mean means of
increasing their body's natural
protection and immunity against
disease it sensibly seeks to gather
experts in the field of natural
autoimmune system health and wellness
and allow them to craft a statewise
curriculum that can be included in our
current health
classes it also seeks to establish a
Statewide advisor in the Department of
Education to act as a centralized
resource and Champion for the new
curriculum while I am generally not a
big fan of expanding government in this
case I feel having someone to oversee
standardize and promote this curriculum
at least initially would be a prudent
investment of tax
dollar the bill seeks to
create curriculum which specifically
identifies the critical role proper diet
nutrition and exercise play in
increasing autoimmune defenses and
reducing many of the conditions related
to comorbidity in a wide variety of
pathogenic
diseases I realized that we have current
health curriculum but I seek a
complimentary curriculum that stresses
to our children the benefits and
importance of developing and maintaining
a good immune uh good immune system
Health in the coming post pandemic age
by teaching our children this criteria
we can reduce their chances of
Contracting disease reduce the severity
of symptoms from disease if they do
contract them reduce their need for
hospitalization or intens of care as
well as helping them avoid conditions
that result in
comorbidity including this in our school
curriculum not only has the potential to
strengthen and protect our individual
students but also to develop stronger
communities and a stronger State I ask
you for support of this legislation and
we'll try my best to answer any
questions you may have thank thank you
very much are there any questions
represent
likeus I'm trying to understand do you
want this to be added to What's Done in
health now or do you want this to be in
addition to What's Done in health
now um my initial intent was to have it
added to what's what's to be done in
health now thank
you forther question representative
Porter thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um I know that there's
some
controversial controversy in the
scientific Community concerning um the
real benefits of vit and dietary
supplements and I'm wondering if that
will present a conflict um
scientifically if it's included in our
curriculum if we're including in our
curriculum items that are perhaps not
scientifically as sound as we would like
them to
be thank you for your
question um in the research I've done in
what I've looked at I haven't found any
um anyone that's saying that a person
that
has
um poor immune system health or a person
that has comorbid morbidities is um at
the same level as someone who has good
immune system health and no
comorbidities as far as dealing with
diseases go
so
um with that in mind
if we know that there are are are things
that we can do in other words we know
that a good diet uh good
nutrition and um exercise help to
strengthen the immune system and we know
that a person with a strong immune
system um has a better chance of dealing
with diseases all of them not just one
specific
one
um I can't see why that would be a an
issue or a problem
can I have a followup Mr chair yes yes
you may thank you I guess that's not the
area of the curriculum that I'm
concerned with um I have also done
research and I know there are many
dietary supplements for example I see
them advertised all the time that if I
took this pill once a day I would
suddenly lose 40 pounds um that a lot of
those dietary supplements and vitamins
are making claims that are not
scientifically
proven um
and I'm worried about teaching our kids
that something will help them when there
is not scientific fact behind
that to prove that it is accurate we
know vitamin C helps us do we really
know if eishia helps us we don't know
for
sure thank you I have the same concerns
actually
um I'm not a
doctor um I'm not a nutrition list I was
taught
that a good diet good nutrition and
exercise help make you healthier and if
you're healthy you tend to be able to
respond better to
diseases um there are quite a few papers
specifically on the increase of of
um of your symptoms when you do get sick
if you have malnutrition or a lack of
vitamins or diseases all I'm looking for
is to teach our
children
what a good diet is what good nutrition
is and how that impacts them from an
immunity
standpoint I think this is a a huge
opportunity it's the one area that we
can actually have an effect on any
disease coming at us in the future and
so I'm really looking to try to um
promote that in our schools if we can
get our children to understand that and
to reduce the number of comorbidities
they develop as they grow older this
will provide us with a stronger
community that can deal better with
diseases as they come
along further questions represent
represent bow then represent
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman
uh than taking the question you know the
uh since you know I'll explain it the
state constitution says if we mandate
something we have to pay for it the
state pays for it so don't you see this
as a 28a
issue for local school
districts that they have to pay for it
without and the con Us New Hampshire
Constitution says if we mandate it we
pay for
it
we're already teaching Health in our
schools um this would be an addition to
a curriculum that already
exists um the additional cost there is a
there was a fiscal note attached there
would be additional cost to it um some
additional cost to
it
the the costs that are
there um
would need to be budgeted for
certain so I I'm thinking that I don't
see it as a if it's done at the state
level the curriculum is developed at the
state level I don't see it as a a a a
um issue that way
um thank you for the question thank you
uh representative
Woodcock thank you representative l good
afternoon almost good afternoon good
late M I guess a couple questions if I
may two or two different areas in the
bill you talking about all public and
private schools um what are you
specifically talking about in terms of
private
schools what I'm trying to do is get a
Statewide curriculum on on uh immune
system
Health um and that that the the state
would provide the you know material and
curriculum for the private schools I I
know that as PRI with private schools
you can't
um you you can't demand that they have
that curriculum but we could provide
them with the information for it so from
a from a dollar standpoint they they
were just using they be accessing our
specialist for their private profit
schools we would be providing
information for them okay from from the
second part you you you commented more
generically in in the curricula you
commented that your your intent uh was
to provide a a good diet and good
nutrition for imunity for youngsters in
the schools that could found
foundational base for them to move on in
their life
um my understanding is that those types
of issues are currently discussed in
health and wellness programs in our
curriculums um in all our high schools
I'm not sure K to8 but in all our high
school curriculum that's already
happening um maybe not to the particular
points of interest that you identify but
by trained uh teachers who are certified
in health and fizzed and nutrition so I
I don't I I guess the problem I I like
what you're saying in terms of what
needs to be done I think a lot of that
is already being done by the
professionals are teaching in the school
every day um and and my my dollar
concern is different than repr restive
across the hall over there my dollar
concern is we're talking about a quar
million dollars a year for doe to to
create a curriculum or higher specialist
in nutrition uh when we already have all
local schools have people doing that
that I guess that's my point I don't
sure it's a point of a question but I
just wonder why we we want to invest a
quarter million dollars for doe to do
that to hire the person when the schools
are already having that in the health
and wellness
curriculums well I agree that the
schools already have that as a health
and and wellness curriculum but I'm also
seeing um data end reports that indicate
that that there is um undernutrition
malnutrition within with children uh so
I'm wondering how effective it's being
and and I think that um we need
to stress this from a immune system
standpoint considering what we've gone
through in the last two years so I I'm
I'm what I'm trying to do is
to um increase the promotion of good
health and wellness within our school
systems thank you repres thank you thank
you uh representative Tanner you had
your hand up I believe thank you um just
as a disclaimer I'm a professional
health and physical education teacher
and um it is taught in the schools uh
it's um taught nutrition is taught and
also physical fitness is taught um and
wellness is taught and um it's very
difficult uh to approach what you're
trying to approach I think and seeing
immediate results have you considered
for example working with the snap
program the food nutrition program for
uh giving to Poverty to uh areas of
places where children can't get enough
food I know one school district in my
area has a backpack program because they
found that kids who have uh limited
access to food at home weren't getting
food on the weekends adequate nutrition
and weren't getting adequate nutrition
over vacations and weren't getting
adequate nutritions up until this last
uh couple of years where schools have
actually taken to providing lunches and
breakfast uh and food to to all students
um the nutrition wasn't there
so you know the curriculum is usually
developed at the local level and I think
uh it would be I was wondering if or how
much you time you had spent actually
with the wellness department at the
State Department of Education the
wellness
coordinator as well as maybe your local
school district to see what is in the
curriculum and what kind of nutritional
benefits they're offering right from the
school that would address the problem
that uh you seem to be trying to address
here I I agree immunity system is you
know that's our first line of
defense thank thank you very thank you
very much are there any further
questions just representative
Ellison
indic
that
legislation funding part would go to
finance well you you've looked at a part
that I've also looked at first of all
the effective date is uh conflicts with
the fiscal note in terms of uh affected
date 60 days after
passage and then you're talking about
these expenditure needs to make this
program work so the something has to be
changed here and uh most likely the
effective date uh curriculum doesn't
happen that
quickly and I think you have a very
excellent
point
concern another committee that's why
this is an early bill it would have to
go to a second committee and that fisal
note would certainly be looked at um and
I'm sure the effective date of the bill
would also be looked at
that yeah thank you you're
welcome any further questions yes
represent
lakus I'm not sure if you're the one to
ask this or if the doe is the one to ask
this I'm wondering if you know why they
feel like they have to have a person
there all these additional years once
they've come up with the
curriculum um I'm probably the person to
ask this and this is this was um this is
the first bill I'm presenting in front
of committee This was um the my seventh
LSR of the year um it came to me from
one of the the people in my district had
the IDE you know had an idea they wanted
me to try to do something about it so I
sat down with them I worked with them um
I tried to talk you know I I worked with
uh legislative services and tried to
talk to them um there are issues with
this bill that I know of there is a
misspelling in the bill that both I and
and legisl legislative Services missed
um I got this bill late coming out of
legislative Services did the best I
could with you know dealing with it but
um I put the language in there and and
there's probably some work that could be
done on that for sure um it's it it was
late I didn't uh have time to actually I
was rewriting two other bills so I
didn't have time to to to redo this one
um
and I certainly have no objection to
amending it to to make it a better
Bill thank thank you very much are there
any further questions not seeing any
hands thank you very much yep we have no
further cards requesting testimony here
on this bill so we shall close this
hearing and take a break for
lunch
obviously he did not talk with doe yeah
or or or agriculture or
anybody I think there defin problems
with that oh yeah oh
yeah responsibility of
the
look on like feel
I
e
yeah well that's what happened to
the
day eat French for
and
100 can't do
it
sure we'll be
back
know
got
you
yeah it's
on m's on now yeah okay like to go ahead
and start on HB
1561 this is a bill relative to school
nutrition standards the bill was do we
have cards up
here uh yeah we need
that thank
you okay I'd like to welcome
representative Shay to our uh education
committee today he is the prime sponsor
of
1561 so that is the first
card go ahead thank you Mr chairman and
uh thank you to the committee for
uh letting me speak this um afternoon uh
sorry a little out of breath I just ran
up here from the the cafeteria I had to
Grapple water real quick during the
lunch period but um so House Bill 1561
uh relative to um to school nutrition
standards so the purpose of this
legislation is to have New Hampshire
adopt better school nutrition standards
than what uh we are currently operating
under the federal guidelines are Wolly
uh inadequate to meet nutritional needs
of New Hampshire's children New
Hampshire should adopt uh some of these
science-based standards cited in House
Bill 1561 will improve uh public and
individual health improve educational
outcomes and decrease long-term public
costs to the state of New Hampshire
investing in school meals and improving
standards helps with a number of
economic and social issues according to
a report conducted by the rockfeller
foundation every dollar invested in
school meals generates about $2 in
economic benefits the same report
explains quote shifting nutritional
quality even further away from foods
like processed meat and those high in
added sugars and toward meal patterns
higher in uh whole grains legumes and
vegetables would further help to prevent
diet related diseases and also have
environmental and climate benefits this
change nationally could yield more than
1.5 billion additional net value each
year the nonpartisan food research and
action center you know Frack for short
reports that quote based on National
Data Economist estimate that the receipt
of a free or reduced price School lch
reduces obesity rates by at least
177% um this could even increase more by
improving our stand standards in the
state of New Hampshire healthier
students with better nutritional habits
will utilize uh they'll utilize less
resources in our healthare system uh
today and later on in
life uh reducing food insecurity at
school also helps many Working Families
manage their budg budgets and save for
other pertinent Investments like
retirement or college um better meals
improves academic outcomes too according
to the food research Action Center um
quote children experiencing hunger are
more likely to be be hyperactive absent
and tardy in addition to having a b
behavioral and attention problems more
often than other children there appears
uh and quote teens experiencing hunger
are more likely to have uh to have been
suspended from school and have
difficulty getting along with other
children end quote children with Hunger
are also more likely to have repeated a
grade receive special education serve
services or receive mental health
counseling than low-income children who
do not experience hunger so these are
people of the same socioeconomic level
um both from uh poor backgrounds but
children who have better meals and who
are better wellfed tend to have higher
educational outcomes and less problems
within the classroom um making students
less hungry and fulfilling their
nutritional needs will hopefully help
those who fall through the cracks which
we sadly see in our school system you
know every year and every day um sadly
our current meals and the poor nutrition
uh promoted by them is uh adding to the
cycle of poverty that we try to end in
this state whether it's through the New
Hampshire advantage or other things uh
New Hampshire has always done things
better than the federal government so
I'm unsure why we would use the federal
government's uh poor School nutritional
standards if we know that they're
heavily influenced by a lot of national
lobbying groups if we know that they're
not always science-based and that
sometimes they're more Guided by um the
interests of some businesses or of other
special interest groups then why would
uh why would states which can be the
Laboratories of democracy not take it
upon the M themselves and decide you
know that we can create better standards
that we're more close to our
constituents and to our school districts
and that we can better understand their
needs
um not only that but uh we should we
should take control of um of of the
needs of our students as we've done you
know in the last number of years and um
create Innovation and coste effective
solutions for granted Staters I think um
I think this the investment that this
legislation would make in helping the
Department of Education Implement these
new standards will have long-term and
short-term benefits for students we're
going to be able to keep more students
in the classroom we're going to make
sure that kids have lower obesity rates
we're going to make sure that the Health
Care system isn't as stressed later on
and that we'll have more healthy
citizens in the state of New Hampshire
and more students we're going to achieve
at a higher level um and with that I'll
uh yield to any questions if the
chairman permits thank you very much
representative represent like
us yes I agree with most of what you
said but your bill doesn't seem to
follow what you actually said you were
talking about innovative solutions in
New Hampshire and following new
technology and science and yet you're
tying this to a certain extent to USDA
USDA um guidelines and stuff which is
old science I noticed for instance whole
grains doctors have pretty much figured
out that while yes whole grains have uh
more vitamins they also have more toxins
lectins which caus cause inflammation
and stuff and a lot of people are on a
diet completely off of whole grains
because of all the inflammation it
caused and so it seems like you're tying
this to old science instead of new
science
um and and you were talking about you
know being flexible and and and um being
able to change and yet you're kind of
tying in with these specific stand
standards and the other things you
talked about vegetables and I would add
fruits to that fruits and vegetables
that's not even in here and that would
be an awesome thing to get more of for
students so I'm wondering why you did
this approach when your goals seem to be
different than what this says um well
thank you for the question
representative leus I I appreciate it
and um some of the nutritional things
that you cited I'd love to see that and
I think you know I assume some of the
nutritionists who are here uh would be
able to comment into a better better
breadth of knowledge I should say depth
of knowledge than myself but um uh based
on some of the things that I've
understood speaking to the state's
nutritionist and speaking to
nutritionists from the American Heart
Association is the vegetable allowance
currently required by the federal
government is pretty lock step in what's
been accepted by um by nutritionists
across the country nutritionists from
the for example the University of uh
Harvard Harvard University who um
they're going to be sending in uh
regarding some of the nutritional bills
that I put in they're going to be
sending in some testimony to uh to the
committee they just got back from their
winter break though so they're a little
bit delayed but hopefully in the next
couple of weeks they will to kind of
address some of those concerns that you
establish but um um I I think some of
the things too is some of the science is
older but it's been well established
right so I know you mentioned you know
for example the whole grains I'm pretty
sure in the bill it was around 1990 some
of these studies were done or you know
the 90s and um some of these things have
been well established and they were even
tried to be previously adopted by the
federal government only for roll backs
to happen right and so we we understand
I think many nutritionists across I
shouldn't say we but nutritionists
across the country and across the state
of New Hampshire understand what the
nutritional needs of students are the
issue is we have a federal government
right now that is um that's not really
Meeting those expectations at least in
my opinion and I think the state of New
Hampshire would do a better job you know
not only of looking over this stuff and
trying to see you know which which kind
of standards are the best ones to adopt
but um but also understanding that we
can we can adopt better standards than
the federal government similar to how
the state of uh Massachusetts done to
our South and it hasn't really increased
costs and it's created better um Better
Health outcomes and better educational
outcomes for a number of students who
depend on these meals in their
classrooms so um I would be more than
happy though to you know and I think it
would be more than uh if the committee
would be more than willing to make
amendments to the bill to nutritional
standards that you might find to be more
um easy easily adaptable to our uh
Public School District and to work with
nutritionists to really find out what
those exact numbers are if you have a
problem with the current numbers and I
think that's I think that's more than a
reasonable approach to take thank you
very much thank you are there further
questions yes representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman
representative Chase how you doing good
good to see you representative yeah
similar um a couple questions I'm
looking at page uh three this is page
two but actually page three I guess uh
on the waiver request uh the r request
talking about no no no school shall be
granted a waiver and then it talks about
except for these exceptions um and then
when I went back to the final part of
your your uh bill under the FN section
it states looking
at almost a half a million dollars
annually to process waivers and
categorize them um seems
like it's talking none and then a few
and then they're talking about six staff
people to do that have you have you had
that Dialogue on numbers with them yep
yep I talked to the state's nutritionist
about that um I would have to have them
speak more to the fiscal note I um I
couldn't imagine you know because I
believe and you are correct um the six
staff members they claimed that they
would need six staff members to
implement to be able to go through these
waiver process and they said especially
because there the number of waivers that
would be needed if covid-19 was still a
major factor to supply chains when this
bill would go into effect which would be
at the end of the budget cycle for the
next bium right so June 1st or no sorry
July 1st of uh 2023 which would also
give School District some time to
implement these kinds of standards um
and to see them coming down the pipeline
um they'd have to speak more as to why
they feel they need six they explain
that that's just what they would need
based on anticipated volume when we
talked they didn't really explain why
they thought the volume would be enough
for six people to uh to go and you know
do these standards uh sorry to to make
these um these uh to process these
waiver applications so that's something
that um it's an ongoing dialogue but the
dialogue did happen that's the number
that they're pretty set on and um I
don't anticipate them changing that
number anytime soon follow up Mr
chairman thank you sir um Al
representative in in uh I'm the same
page I'm looking at line 24 is talking
about the the curricular impact uh we
you were creating a curriculum for a K
to 12 or they would be the St I guess
for K 12 instruction now it's my
understanding that a lot of the
nutritional information information
because it's a it's a curriculum that
would be uh taught in the classroom was
already
ongoing so I don't know that if that's
part of their Staffing piece for
curriculum
or it might be but when we had that
conversation that wasn't something that
we touched upon but I can certainly um I
can reach back out to the nutritionist
and I can get back to you on that well
just the just the CL Clarity it's all I
need on on 3A are you anticipating say
that the pro this program is going to uh
have hat in hand with the the food piece
they're going to create a new curriculum
for all schools and that's I'm looking
at
three uh a line 24 through 26 here let
me let me grab a
copy
what page is that again representative
my apologies it says page two it's
actually it's page two on the do the
page two it's line 24 through 26 line 24
through 26 yeah I think that looks to be
current current law okay so so they're
not going to be creating that so no
that's already that's already
established yeah okay it's already in
place yep thank you thank you Mr
chairman my apologies also
representative for the confusion
representative Mullen thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um so there's a considerable
price tag associated with those six
staff members and of note for me is the
fact that those staff members would be
looking to support 520 public and
chartered public schools and also 137
nonpublic schools so my uh question
is did you consider a way that
non-public schools might be
held accountable for participating in
the costs of those staff members I mean
I I just I I don't think I'm incorrect
that the Department of Education has no
jurisdiction over the non-public schools
so I'm not sure I'm looking at the
statement from uh the fiscal note the
backside of the fiscal note yeah says
under this proposed legislation onps
would be required to now support up to
520 public schools to include chartered
Public Schools as well as 137 nonpublic
schools so um if you uh representative
did not consider that factor I would
like to hear from the Department of Ed
on
where they see themselves in this
process with non-public
schools yeah and I'm I'm unsure if
someone from the Department of Education
is here from the nutrition program but I
can certainly take down that question
and uh follow up with you repres it's
okay I'm looking at them they're they're
here are there further
questions we will get to where you were
represent Mullen when
we're
represent
leas yes and in a followup to um
representative Woodcock on the section
on waivers I'm wondering why you just
had to waiver to
covid-19 um there can be other supply
chain issues floods hurricanes whatever
uh do schools not get a waiver for those
supply chain issues only for covid
um in this legislation way I've written
it it's uh the same kind of waiver
process that would be done that I think
we have established for some of the um
some the novelty of the covid-19 um
issue that we have going on right now
I'm not sure if there's any other
waivers from the Department of Education
where they wave national food standards
or you know currently the state doesn't
have any food standards for uh for um
for School meals but I don't think we
have any process for waving the national
standards I'm not sure if the national
government does but I think that that's
a good question for the uh for the
nutritionist from the Department of
Education or the department of
education's Representative but I'll
certainly um if it isn't addressed I'll
write that question down I'll follow up
with you thank you are there further
questions not yes repesent
cordelli thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um in terms of meeting
these Target two target three Target
four
levels um that are acquired um in uh
future years um is there anything in law
that prevents um a district from um
meeting these uh targets uh now or uh in
earlier years than specified in the
bill I don't think there's anything in
law that inhibits a school district but
I'm not sure if we've done anything to
enable a school district from doing so
um this would certainly it would require
it but I'm not sure if anything um and
you can correct me Mr Vice chairman or
someone from the Department of Education
correct me if I'm mistaken but um to my
understanding the school districts
follow the federal guidelines and uh the
ru making that comes from the federal
government on School
meals I should also thank you for your
question my apologies I should have
started with that are there further
questions not seeing any thank you very
much thank you and thank you for
listening today I appreciate it
we have a a card now from Nancy vaugh
American Heart
Association
good afternoon chairman lad and members
of the committee um for the record I am
Nancy vaugh government relations
director for the American Heart
Association in New Hampshire um I've
handed out written testimony so I'll
I'll try not to read um verbatim from
from my uh my my written words um but I
just want to start by saying um that the
American Heart Association greatly
supports the passage of this bill um uh
our organization um has been working on
um child nutrition um policy efforts for
a number of years including working
closely at the federal level um on the
uh healthy hunger free kids act um and
this this really starts with that act um
signed into law back in 2010 um and then
going into effect for um The Years 2012
and 2016 on some of the the
science-based on nutrition standards for
kids um and when this did go go into
effect um for for state level school
districts um it it was a learning curve
it was a a great deal of effort put into
it and I applaud School F Food Service
directors for doing as much as they have
um in in imp um putting into place these
uh these guidelines and 99% of schools
pre pandemic actually were meeting the
standards of the federal government um
but what happened um in the last several
years is there have been some efforts um
to put pressure on the USDA to either
roll back some of their um their
standards um or to delay the
implementation and I think what we're
seeing now or I know what we're seeing
now is just the fact that the USDA has
not enforced some of the the food
standards that we are addressing um uh
today in the conversation around this
bill um mainly de deal dealing with
sodium levels um the whole grain levels
I know there's a question on and also
added sugars um so first of all I just
um want to to say on the sodium level
what we um what we know is that um
children are are eating consuming far
too much sodium as all of us are in the
foods that we eat a lot of that is
because of processed foods but they're
still consuming too much sodium even in
the school um School Meal program
because those targets that were were
questioned and discussed a moment ago um
that were set to put to be put into
place in a staggered um method which is
being done with this build as well um
we're we're pulled back on at the
federal level um so we are looking at
this again as um representative Des said
of having a New Hampshire standard that
starts with the federal um food program
standards but expands upon them for
these science-based changes that have
not been made at the federal level um
and uh and obviously I'm not going to
get into all the health reasons that's
in my testimony because you are are the
the education committee um um but it is
for health reasons we we just need to
really help children grow to be as
healthy as they possibly can with the
foods that we're serving um particularly
in school um uh so we we are looking at
meeting the targets that if the federal
government does suddenly say we are now
going to enforce the targets with all
the school lunch programs that we we put
into play a timeline um and then you'll
notice the words or um by the time that
the um USDA makes these changes so we
are not in any way saying that schools
can't meet these standards now it's just
they they they meet the standards when
the USDA says okay now this is this is
when it goes into play and and um
corporations who are making the foods
for schools um to serve to students are
then also forced to to make those um
those uh those changes with their
formulations um I am not aware um too
much on the the science around toxicity
of whole grains with but it may very
well be with with some individuals and I
believe school districts would make
allowances for for children's particular
individual um food um uh sensitivities
as well um but again obviously
nutritionist will say um more about that
than than I can I'm not a nutritionist
um so again sodium is of particular
concern to us the whole grains is a
concern to us the added sugars I don't
believe there were really strong
standards put into place around added
sugars and again children and all of us
are taking in far too many added sugars
and um in the the beverages that we're
consuming fortunately at the school
level we have taken sugary um drinks out
of um the the school environment for for
the most part which is very good though
it's still still kind of there um but
this is really in the Foods um that um
that would be served to to Children
looking at um science-based standards
and I believe the um the dietary
standards for Americans call for no more
than 10% of calories to be from added
added sugars in in the foods that that
children eat and we'd like schools to be
following that as well um I think that
pretty much covers what I really wanted
to um to focus on um and if there is any
information that we can provide after
this this hearing um or even today if
it's something I just I know of I can
answer for you I will um I'm happy to
work with the committee on gain more
information to you so so thank you very
much for taking my testimony I hope that
you will consider this bill um and and
ways that we can can pass it to make
sure we're serving children as close to
science um recommended um nutrients as
we can in schools thank you very much
for your presentation uh are there any
questions at this time not seeing thank
you very much okay thank
you we don't have any are there any
other folks here that have pink cards
and represent Mullen would you like to
speak to anybody from the
Department I
would so we have several people from the
Department back there come on up thank
you Mr chairman yep you're
welcome welcome
again thank you and again McKenzie snow
um division director of learner
support um Kelly Rambo administrator for
nutrition programs and
services
representa Mullen you want to lead I'm
on I'm on okay so um thank you very much
for coming and answering questions this
afternoon so there are references in and
around the bill to the Department of
Education both from you know the state
board and the role of doe in developing
curriculum to uh the six new potential
positions that would have to be created
to manage the the new program so my
questions are about uh whether or not
you can let us know if you currently are
doing anything with schools that are
non-public and whether or not um you do
things with schools that don't
participate in the national school lunch
program thank you and first we do want
to say that we appreciated um
representative des's request for and his
attention to um the technical assistance
previously provided to the by the
department um so the the reason why it
would require significant additional
staff capacity and the department
actually submitted to LBA uh an estimate
of three to six additional staff is
because currently our office of
nutrition programs and services
implements federal regulations that
follow federal funds this would add
state regulations to nonparticipants ANS
in the national school lunch program
that are more stringent than the
existing Federal requirements so this
doesn't establish um in a sense it
establishes New Hampshire's uh unique
requirements but it actually a as
previously testified to um identifies
Target levels in the areas of sodium
grains and sugars um that were set by
the USDA but were not executed
implemented required by the USDA um for
their stated reasons of concern around
supply chain and decreasing
participation um in uh School provided
lunches because of um student concern
around taste uh so so hopefully that
provides some clarity in addition to um
now implementing both a federal
regulatory schema and a new State uh set
of requirements we would need to as
stated evaluate provide and then report
upon uh waivers to these state
requirements we do currently implement
covid-19 related USDA waivers and report
that to USDA but those are all under the
federal regulatory schema um and then
just one additional Point uh that we'd
bring up is around the implementation
timeline and ensuring that we draw
attention to the 60 days after passage
implementation timeline which we would
find um not feasible to implement uh and
then specifically to your question
around um non-public schools currently
non-public schools some nonu Public
Schools participate through their SA
saus or leas but there are no State
nutrition requirements um applied to
nonparticipants um participants or
non-public
schools thank you you have a followup go
ahead yes thank you Mr chair so um in
your
experience do you have a sense of how
the nonpublic world would feel
feel about these regulations being
placed upon
them we have not conferred with the
nonpublic school Community or individual
non-public school leaders or teachers um
about the uh what it would take for them
to uniquely Implement these requirements
but they are um observably significant
new
requirements thank you I I have a
question for you uh then represent boom
um this bill references that the
department shall be responsible for
preparing and uh Distributing a
curriculum associated with this bill it
also states that the State Board shall
develop rules according to
541a uh
regarding uh the Rel relative policies
associated with this bill so my question
is um
in looking at the development of
curriculum when the department has been
engaged seeing that curriculum is primar
primarily a responsibility of the local
school
district how long and does your process
take in order to develop a curriculum
I'm not talking about standards I'm
talking about the
curriculum how long will it take you to
develop a curriculum if you in fact work
with School District Personnel put
together a task force come up with
recommendations and then get approval
for that curriculum uh from the state
board um and rules the same thing is it
is it realistic to believe that this is
all going to be ready to go within a
one-year period of
time so currently we do not um develop
and disseminate curriculum um in any
area it is a local uh decision what
curriculum to adopt the State Board of
Education approves state standards as
you stated so um that would be a
significant um shift in the roles
between state and local
governments so and followup the State
Board in this bill is responsible for
developing a curriculum I.E the
department and that is a shift from
where we've been in terms of other
topics like history government
mathematics Etc correct we do not create
or um endorse or disseminate curriculum
thank
you uh represent B you were next thank
you Mr chairman thank take a question to
follow up on representative Mull's
question which I didn't hear an answer
to Is what about public schools that do
not participate in the federal food
program which there off
some yep so there um and that was
constituted in the
466 uh non-public schools currently
participating in an SL SLP in about 520
total schools um so those schools that
are not current total Public Schools
those schools not currently
participating um would be required to
comply with new state requirements um
regardless of their participation in the
nslp program um in regardless of their
receipt of federal
funds follow up yes thank you um one of
the reasons schools aren't participa
ating because nobody was eating the food
that was being required so how is this
going to make students want to eat the
food I I can't really speak to um how it
would affect individual student
taste do you have another question
represent B no you're good
representative cardelli uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you again for being
here um going back to the section on
rules um on bottom of page two and top
of Page Three um it requires the
department to come up with rules um
including a model physical activity
policy that uh I would like to ask about
as well as um a rule regarding technical
assistance and compliance reporting
requirements
um do you have any thoughts on the
development of uh either of those rules
because developing a rule related to
policy seems
unusual I I'm not entirely sure what's
encapsulated in the intent of uh what
What's meant to be covered by State
Board of Education rulemakings and
perhaps um representative desay what
could better clarify the intent behind
uh the topics to be
covered
so just to clarify perhaps what
represent cordelli is going after
um we get regulation from F federal
government when we establish statute
rule is made to support that statute to
align and parallel with the
statute I think he's trying to say and I
don't want to put words in his mouth but
policy we don't develop rules for
policy I think it's that clear um is
that where you were thank
you you put the words in my mouth
nicely okay further questions yes
represent
whitcock thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon again um couple questions
going back to a follow up on um
represent mullen's uh initial thinking
uh when you're when they're talking
about the other uh schools it's about 60
I guess from the 460 520 that are not
participating now um does the department
a couple questions do the department
have any knowledge or why they aren't
participating besides the the one that
was presented um and secondly how would
you how would you monitor you're talking
about expand monitoring of the 137
nonpublic schools how do you do
that so it would be a significant um
expansion of our current monitoring
responsibilities which again apply only
to participants and um are only for the
existing Federal requirements so we we
both add a significant number of
participants about a 40% increase in the
number of schools monitored um or or or
subject to Lea monitoring um or are
monitoring of school districts just to
be clear um but perhaps uh Kelly if you
want to speak to reasons why some uh
public schools and school districts
choose not to participate in an
SLP
thank you for the question um there are
some schools that that do not
participate um that that's their choice
alone and to McKenzie's point before um
it could be due to the fact that the
regulations that have been made the
participation has declined due to um the
students taste pallets let's say so to
speak um for for those particular
schools okay thank you one follow yes
thank you president chair um the last
one the standards that you said that the
department follows under the ons
program the USDA
regulations um how do they
compare uh significantly or not to the
recommendations that represent of the
shades is brought under the new
regulations so you'll note in the in the
build text um it it articulates Target
levels um that are across the board I
think one in excess of the current
Target level so USDA set these Target
levels there was a plan to move forward
and Implement these Target levels that
USDA did not execute um in part because
of the current Supply supply chain
constraints that would be exacerbated um
by that I think it's also important to
note that the supply chain um may or may
not be responsive uh if our state
requirements change because they are
used to National requirements
okay thank you Mr chair thank you any
further
questions uh I have one last one for go
ahead repon
Hopson I'm sorry I had a question more
about um the the actual bill not for the
department but for the bill sponsor so I
I'm sorry to ask now is it possible to
find
out after or should I
just um if what time we have here that's
okay I can ask we may have the time for
that okay uh I do have one for the
Department um in looking at this bill
and being responsible for the food
service programs at the department have
you seen any legislation similar to this
in other states here in our country and
if so um have you identified any issues
or any both positive and negative that
have come out of this program that we
should know about
we do not have any um best practices or
lessons learned from other states that
have considered such proposals that's
something that we could look into in our
network of um similarly situated State
Education Agency nutrition
programs thank you are there further
questions of the
department okay what we're going to do
is to representative desay are you
willing to come back to the chair and
take another grueling
question I I would love to
okay this hot thank you repres chair lad
and thank you representative Dees for
taking my question I promise you it's
not grueling um on page I guess it would
be the actual text of the bill line 21
nutrition standards for all foods sold
outside of school meals um I'm thinking
of bake sales carb nights pizza
parties um are those now off the
table I think that that's more related
to um to fundraisers if uh if I remember
correctly um so for example if like a
school club wants to sell let's say well
this is an issue we actually ran into in
my high school so I can speak from
experience being there you know just
about six years ago is um there's only a
certain allotment how much like pizza
you can sell like club events or you
know chocolate bars you can sell as a
fundraiser right unhealthy food that you
can sell so we used to have our Quiz Bow
team which actually held our state
championship in the lob every year um we
would sell candy bars and other clubs
because we would do our we took
precedence and we'd sell candy bars
twice a year other clubs wouldn't be
able to sell candy bars because our club
utilized um the most uh the the
allotment of candy that could be sold by
clubs during uh school hours I'm not
sure I don't think it would affect the
school district allowing clubs to sell
for example like outside of school hours
um to utilize facilities to have their
own kind of private fundraisers or to
get supplemental funding for a sports
team I think it's just specific for
what's happening during the school hours
I could be mistaken though um that
almost might be a better question for
the Department of Education um
so okay I understand your reluctance
that's
fine
okay well there's nothing else you know
thank you and I have a lot of notes to
uh to to attend to probably this evening
and over the next few days so um but you
have one more hand over represent or is
that for me yes sir good um represent I
just want to make sure I'm clear on this
as I look at this bill and and because
think about what uh the representative
across the room just
said am I correct to assume that the
only information that that
representative the Shay's uh bill is
changing from current law is just the
ones that italics inv
Bol it's just I didn't get the last part
no that wrong no I I I say I didn't hear
what you said okay it's just the the
italics part and the Bold the Bold
italics is that the only part that
represented the Shay's bill is actually
changing no okay so the whole thing I
don't think so okay the whole piece
we're looking at a whole lot that's new
here want to be sure
thank you I just I didn't know why that
was highlighted that's all that that we
used to get uh bills for the highlighted
was the change right now it's you got to
read between the
lines every line thank you
yeah okay are there any other questions
for the
representative not seeing thank you very
much thank you for having me and thank
you for entertaining me
today so that that
conclude uh all those that have wanted
to speak here on this particular bill so
we will close uh HB
1561 and the next one starts at
215 yeah you can go out and get a
soda
e
well it
does
e
thank you very much Mr chair and it's a
pleasure to uh to be with uh with all of
you esteemed uh committee colleagues
this afternoon uh I know it's been a
long day and we've got a couple of luno
bills to uh to get through uh next and
so we'll try to make these as uh as
painless and as uh expeditious as
possible so um again thank you it's
great to join you for the record my name
is Dave luno representing the people of
hopkington and conquered um House Bill
1684 uh is a simple bill and it's a
straightforward bill and it's a bill
that has integrity and
accountability and calls for honesty
from our executive branch leaders who
write budgets and spend tax
money and it's a bill that will give
lawmakers the chance to question these
Executives about how they spend or how
they want to spend taxpayer money to
make sure that it's being spent wisely
and to make sure that we're not getting
on a runaway
train the education Freedom account
program has the potential has the
potential to become a train wreck and
that's not good for anybody just in the
first year of the program progam it's a
Runway a runaway train in June back in
June just a few months ago the
Department of Education recommended a
budget for the education Freedom account
program for the full year fy21 of
$129,000 but by November the cost had
already shot up to over $8
million so how did this
happen the department used participation
rates based on similar program in
Arizona the department had estimated
that 75% of the students who participate
would directly exit their public school
for an EFA another 15% would uh who
would already um would already be
attending uh private schools when they
take uh when they when they take an EFA
and final 10% would be from
homeschools According to the
Department's budget information document
the the savings Advantage for New
Hampshire taxpayers is when an EFA
student comes directly from their Public
School presumably saving the local
property taxpayer from having to pay
their per pupil cost to educate the
student and not costing the state any
more than what it was already paying for
that student in terms of
adequacy dollars coming from the
education trust fund and the cost for
the private and homeschool students who
take the EFA would not lead to any
savings for local taxpayers and would in
fact be new costs for the state
amounting to between $4,000 and 8,000
per student also coming from the
education trust fund and that's all
presented in the Department's um uh
comprehensive long-term uh Financial
projection but unfortunately that's not
what happened as we learned in November
only 177% of EFA students came from
their Public Schools not
75% and a whopping 83% were already
students in private and home schools
these students who had already made the
choice to leave their Public Schools
weren't costing the state a dime but now
we're all paying for it so where could
it go from
here there are approximately and I'm
rounding approximately 170,000 New
Hampshire students who attend public
schools grades K through 12 and there's
another approximately 16,000 students
who attend private schools and 3,000 who
are
homeschooled and uh those numbers come
from a from the doe um uh comprehensive
model analysis as well and of those
students in private and home schools
maybe
75% are Income eligible under the
current EFA law given this the director
of legislative budget assistant office
projects State exposure to be closer to
$75 million a year a far cry from the 29
I'm sorry $75 million a year a far cry
from the 129,000
projected the LBA concludes with a
statement just to clarify this is in no
way an estimate of the actual State
fiscal impact and only illustrates the
potential State exposure versus what doe
assumptions are for non-public school
students so this is where we can do
better H Bill 1684 would stop The
Runaway Train the department would be in
the position to present and defend a
budget that goes to the state objectives
of the program for instance to provide
students from low-income backgrounds
access to educational op education
opportunities outside of their public
schools and the department could be
questioned by lawmakers to make sure
taxpayer money is actually being used to
open doors for students and
families I hope the committee will look
favorably on truth and budgeting budget
integrity and the obligation to spend
taxpayer money wisely thank you for your
time this afternoon I'm happy to take
any
questions I have two questions if that's
okay actually I have more but
I'll
um the parents who are homeschool you're
talking about the increase cost um
coming from the parents that the state
is now having to spend more money for
those homeschool parents aren't those
homeschool parents paying taxes the same
as everybody else and aren't they right
now actually saving the local public
schools money by not being in the public
schools that's money that the public
schools would have had to spend for
those students but they're homeschooled
so it seems to me that this is a a
benefit and and if you're you often talk
about fairness seems to me fair if a
parent is paying all the taxes of
everybody else the least they can get is
the amount that the state spends for
Education they're not taking the amount
the local school spends so I mean I
don't
understand I don't understand how you
can why you're coming down against the
poor people who are are you know asking
for this money when the state is running
$120 million surplus at the moment why
are we taking money away from poor
people poor students who weren't able to
get the appropriate education in their
schools and ended up homeschooling or
private schooling so um not coming down
on that at all just it's completely
completely inconsistent with the program
as presented by the Department of
Education where 75% of the students were
going to be direct exits from their
local public schools and provide
immediate um uh reduction in local
taxpayer obligations I'm not saying
anything about about um whether or not
whether or not homeschoolers should be
should be getting these or private
school kids should be getting these but
that's not what was presented by the
commissioner
oh your mic yeah as I understood the
process when implementing the voucher
system that only that the facult the
school system got to retain 20% of the
money from the local thing 80% went to
the but all of the state and federal
money went to the school system from
from which that student so they still
got all of that money with no cuts and
they didn't have to instruct a student
so it doesn't sound as destructive as it
sounds as you presented and I don't mean
that in a majority thing about what you
said it's just the numbers it it sounds
to me like the impact is
less can I interject for just a second
please yes uh the the the numbers you're
just uh mentioning and alluding to come
from HB
607 okay yeah it's a different bill
that's the local education Freedom
account first okay the freedom account I
would be happy to to address what the
what the um uh
incremental oh
yeah it's on
off
I
can it off like that a little
bit
e
hello
hello thanks thanks oliv just thanks
Oliver yeah th this uh this works good
thanks um so there there is a provision
in hb2 stemming from the hb20 language
that that does provide for a um for for
um for school districts where an EFA
student is a direct exit out of that
school district where there's a um where
there's a a taper of the um of the
adequacy um loss inadequacy dollars from
the state and that tapers off I forget
after two or three years something like
that um um there also the um I'm not an
expert on the uh the idea the federal
dollars but um but if the students gone
from the public school districts I don't
I don't believe believe that the uh that
the school district continues to receive
those Federal
Ida not not in not in the hb2 EFA
program so so I we're referencing 607
again I think the 6 in 607 they are
still in the ADM but not in yeah yeah
but but I but those are good questions
but along those same same lines
representative Ford um
I think what um what what this
illustrates is
that thanks that the that the thank you
very much that the draw of the program
isn't necessarily from um from public
schools as it was presented being 75%
being a draw from from public schools
it's 83% at least from this initial
Year's experience coming from non-public
school students and uh and that's really
where State impact
costs uh become significant because if
it's a if it's from a public school it's
a push the state either sends the
adequacy payment to the public school or
to the EA but when the student comes
from a private school or a home school
that's a new obligation that the state
is taking on uh out of the education
trust fund which isn't like just sort of
of money growing on trees the EFA is a
is a budgeted amount and it's budgeted
based on the um the um the the
projections that come from the
Department of of education for public
schools and the projection that comes
from the Department of Education for
efas and so when an EFA is is under
budgeted by by nearly $8 million as it
was this time um that puts a that puts a
strain on the education trust fund that
it really wasn't designed to
handle further questions from the
presenter from the committee represent
cordelli thank you Mr
chairman one two
two like check one
two thanks Glen sure thank
you you
mentioned
phion
language your budget caps 22
and3 do those numbers include phas as
well for local school
districts oh good question on that I
don't think they do because I took those
directly out of the
um I took those directly out of the the
Department's um uh budget spreadsheets
which I which I sent around so so for
example the the
129,000 is uh is um is the sum of the uh
i' I've circled a a package of numbers
and you could see public uh public
school to non-public option non public
school and then home education it's the
sum of those um those three three
numbers there so it doesn't include the
taper but but then again the the taper
um rather than affecting 75% of the uh
of the students is only affecting 133%
of the U I'm sorry 17% of the students
so um so it would it would likely be a
much more diminus uh number but but
something that certainly should be
considered
uh thank you Mr chairman
um since these um amounts uh affect uh
22 and
23 um1
129,000 uh dollar uh for
22 um what happens to the children who
have received uh EFA funds already ready
if we are capping um the program at the
$129,000 yeah so again I think that's uh
that's that's an important uh
consideration to make because uh if the
uh if the mone's already you know um you
know left the education trust fund for
the for the efas it's uh not likely
you're going to be able to claw that
back and um and I think um certainly uh
provision could be could be put in place
place where where where maybe that cap
starts in um in in FY 23 or something
like uh uh like
that yeah thank you Mr chair thank you
representative luno for taking my
question and um and thank you for
flagging the numbers that you flagged
because it's a very legitimate uh
situation that does need attention but I
want to follow up a little bit on
representative cordell's concern which I
share I think you share we all share is
to would a measure that like this or an
amended measure like this move forward
what happens to the students that are
commit the current or prospective
students that are looking at EFA
opportunities and uh there are obviously
there are the reasons that students from
wherever they come from are their
families are opting for efas or for
safety reasons or whatever is best for
the student so if if you given any
thought as to to follow up on the
previous question if you given any
thought as the criteria for severing
students from the EFA program who uh are
in that because I think that if this
moves forward then there would have to
be a process and criteria for severing
students from the program is there been
any consideration or a plan for that you
know not really I think that's a great
question representative Moffett um uh
and I think that's something that uh
that I'd be delighted to work with uh
with this Committee in in terms of of
putting together and again when you when
you take a look at the the you know the
recur the the the the theme of this
effort it's to stop a train
wreck uh I think we would probably all
agree if uh if if this um you know went
to to to you know perhaps the uh uh to
the to the extent of uh of of of of
State exposure that the LBA had um had
identified that that that would be an
unsustainable and and untenable position
so I think it would be important to uh
to stop it before it gets that far so
it's obviously gotten gotten uh gotten
pretty far out of hand even in this
first year 129,000 to almost $8.1
million so um and uh and and and not as
a result of Public School uh student
exits but as a result of private and
home um uh participation in the uh in
the program so um so I think there's
probably a number of ways that that
could um could could provide support for
these um for these students uh uh also
keeping in mind that um that that these
students and their families and I and I
certainly am am not trying to to to um
underestimate the the the the struggle
and and commitment and effort that
families put in to uh to educating their
um their their children but uh but these
weren't these weren't kids that that
were just pulled out of their public
schools these are students who who had
been in a non-public school situation
prior to the uh the um um U offering of
the EFA
program thank
you I wonder your objection to having
every single student in the state if
that's what if that's who decides to use
this to use this because isn't the state
supposed to provide the opportunity for
an adequate education for every single
student and isn't $4,000 an awful small
amount to have to pay to provide that if
every single student decides this if our
train goes down the track far enough
that every single student decides to use
it aren't we in effect saving money if
money is what you're worried about and
if educating students is what you're
worried about then that's a pretty cheap
education yeah I'd say I'd say $4,000
does get you a pretty cheap education
and we'll uh we'll talk about that some
more I think in the next um in the next
bill we're going to we're going to hear
this afternoon but um but uh to be to be
uh to be clear the state does not have
an obligation a constitutional
obligation to to provide an adequate
education for every child in New
Hampshire it has an it has a
constitutional obligation to cherish
Public Schools that's those are the
exact words from the Constitution and
that's very different than what you're
talking
about yes um um I just wonder what the
definition of public schools because it
seems to me that if the public is paying
for the education it is a public school
whether it is a building funded by a
town or a home school funded by the
state that sounded like debate to me
that was a question I said I wonder at
that at your
definition so what is your definition of
public education yeah I think the
definition of public schools is pretty
well understood it's uh pretty well
defined in
statute and um uh and I think there's
there's pretty clear definition uh
between Public School Public Charter
School um uh I think homeschooling is in
the statute I think private schools are
also in in statute so um so I I I think
there's a lot of uh definition on that
but uh but I'm not an attorney
representative leakas so uh so I would
certainly um um you know defer to uh to
you know an an attorney from the
Department if um if attorney Fenton is
still with us this
afternoon I do thank you uh chairman L I
can't even see him that may be a good
thing repres little yeah we have that
problem here it's uh dodging um I just
want to make sure I'm accurate on
this the EFA and if if I get representa
light if I get the wrong bill please
stop me um using your numbers the EFA
that that's currently inv vog uh that
has expended this money was actually
identifi for a small number of
youngsters um hopefully a small number
of youngsters that were coming from
Public School uh and looking the data
you have here and the things I've read
myself you're talking 83 84% I'd heard
um those youngsters were not even in the
public schools so the deficit is cost is
caused if I understand this correctly by
folks that were not ever enrolled at
that time in the public school so is
that accurate that's that's correct okay
so the second part is on these two
numbers you have here the 129 which may
be a legitimate number for the the
number that the commissioner had thought
might participate um so basically just
funding people who weren't here but the
8 $8 million you have identified as the
actual cost as of this writing this
document how where does that deficit
come from where how no where's the
repayment or the
funding for that money come from thank
you for the uh for the question
representative Woodcock um and that's
that's um sort of what I was what I was
um um you know talking about when I was
uh when I was addressing representative
Ford's question that the education trust
fund which is used to provide all of the
state's adequacy um payments to to all
of our school districts uh and uh and uh
provides the uh the funding of uh of
efas that's a limited fund that's it's
not the it's um it's it's something
that's budgeted by the the finance uh
committee uh perhaps representative
walls might uh might might be able to
shed shed a little bit of process light
uh on it but um the education trust fund
is not the state's general fund um it's
um it's it's um it's budgeted based on
what the doe uh projects as being its
Public School adequacy payment needs for
the banum plus uh any additional needs
that um that are funded through the the
ETF uh including U the the education
Freedom accounts and so when a budget is
off
by almost by $8 million in uh in this
case uh either an additional
appropriation has to be made from the
general fund to be put into the
education trust fund or uh or something
else get squeezed and uh one of the
things that that have been have been
squeezed in the past is um is special
education Aid which used to be called
catastrophic Aid in New Hampshire I
believe the title was changed just a few
uh years ago but um but um uh when when
funds are not sufficient in the
education trust fund to reimburse uh
school districts for special education
costs that gets
pro-rated so there's an example of where
it gets
squeezed thank you thank thank you
chairman yes I'm wondering in the those
that came from private schools or P or
um home schools and those that came from
from
um town schools I'm
wondering have you looked at how many of
them had originally been or a family
member had originally been in the public
schools and had had left before that
because they weren't getting an adequate
education so thank you I I have not
because that information has not been
released by the department I'm not even
sure it was collected by the department
but I would be very interested in uh in
and having a better understanding of uh
of exactly what those circumstances uh
were or are and um and um but and thank
you very much and I hope you'd uh you'd
you'd support the department providing
that
information to to this
committee great thank you very
much
for
did I do this right oh I did um good
afternoon representatives and thank you
for the opportunity to speak I am
speaking today in opposition of House
Bill
1684 education Freedom accounts is
access to the freedom for parents and
Guardians to choose the best learning
environment for their CH for their child
or
children it is the
freedom of the parents and Guardians to
choose the best learning environment for
their child or children it is the
freedom to have a small percentage of
the tuition rate of a child to have the
option to attend private or Charter
Schools or even homeschooling without
education Freedom we are expected that
learning as a one- siiz
fits-all approach is is the only major
option did you know that house spill
1684 would cut the opportunity for at
about
1,856 children children down to 26
children in
total where is the fairness and equality
in that 100% normally received in
funding by by the public education
system of that only 30% would go towards
the families for the education Freedom
account 70% of the funding Still Remains
in the public homeschool District of
that child which means they have
additional funding for one less child
house bill would cut that down again
1,856 students currently being able to
have the education freedom to attend the
best learning environment for them would
cut down to 26 will any one of you be
one of the ones to tell them that they
cannot get their best educational
advancements I sure hope that I wouldn't
be one of those this program is not only
an amazing opportunity for students
throughout New Hampshire but it's
necessary for their educational best
interests now let me take a brief moment
to explain a personal situation for
myself and my children I'm a parent of
two Nash School District children one of
which has a 504 and the other has an i
one of my children does exceptionally
well in public education the other child
however struggles they've struggled
through the course of this pandemic
they've struggled with un enforcement of
the 504 program which has led me to a
place where I feel that the best
educational investment for my child is
not the public school system for our
youngest it may or may not be a montau
based school or a charter school or even
a private school at that matter or even
homeschooling here is the problem I am a
single parent I make less than most of
the most of the people that are
qualified to appropriately send their
child to private or charter schools
because a lot of people that are in
those Realms that uh representative luno
had mentioned before that were already
in the private or Charter section they
were able to afford that without
education Freedom accounts and the
children's scholarship fund my children
will not only not be able to attend
those schools it's not even an option
for a family Like
Mine by limiting the budget on this
particular bill you are limiting not
just the budgetary options like I said
before out of 100% of what the
homeschool District receives in funding
only 30% of that goes towards the
education Freedom account for the family
only 30% that still leaves 70% of the
total amount for that tuition cost to
remain in the district and they're
teaching one less student that seems
like a very good benefit to me when you
think about the public education system
currently the public education system is
designed for a one-size fits-all out of
those
1,856 children in the program right
now do you really feel that only 26 of
those families know what's best for
their children no there are so many more
and by limiting the opportunity to
participate in an education Freedom
account by putting a budget and a small
budget is irrational and completely
unconscionable when you think about what
is the best interest of the children I
want to close with I know that
representative luno had stated earlier
the words consist inconsistency and
train wreck given the inconsistency in
many districts throughout this past two
years and what the public education
system has unveiled to the parents with
within those Educational Systems it is
already an educational train wreck for
students who do not fit into the public
education one siiz fits-all please vote
no on House Bill 1684 thank
you
yes yes if anybody has any
questions thank you thank you for being
here um when you mentioned the seven and
30 and um the child is not there to
educate um
are are you referring to 70 being local
funds versus 30% being State funds or
how are you arrived at that split so I
actually worked very hard um as a parent
to advocate for Education Freedom
accounts to begin with and the funding
that they receive from the state level
and the local level 100% of that goes
into the education of the child is my
understanding Now with an education
Freedom account if that same child
enters into an education Freedom account
30% of that 100% is the only amount that
goes with the child for the education
Freedom account itself the other
remaining 70% still stays within the
within the budget that goes to the
homeschool District or the District home
where the school is where the child
resides does that answer your question
okay
okay thank
you
I want to thank you all for having me
and my children here today um we're here
in opposition of this bill um we are
participants in the EFA program and we
were homeschoolers prior to this but my
children were also in public school
prior to that we had to remove them two
of my children have Tourette Syndrome my
oldest daughter who you'll hear from in
a moment um was in a coma and has memory
issues public public school just didn't
work for her and the Tourette's really
put a hindrance on my children's my
other children's education in the public
school system so we moved to
homeschooling and the EFA money has
given us the opportunity to get them
working computers classes that we
wouldn't have had access to um my
husband and I are both disabled and so
our income is very limited and so this
money has been such a blessing to us us
to be able to give our children the kind
of education that they deserve and I
heard a lot of talk about budgets and
and money and things like that to the
public schools but my children deserve
just as much of a chance to have a
quality education as children who are
attending Public
Schools um I'm sorry that I don't have
numbers or impact reports to give to you
but I can tell you that personally this
bill would absolutely hurt my family
firstly I don't even understand how we
can talk about limiting to a budget of a
hundred something thousand dollars when
all of these other students have already
gotten their dispersements I mean does
that mean that I'm going to have to pay
the money back that we've already used
towards their education from the EA
funds are they going to come after our
tax money that we had already paid into
this fund to repay it um I understand
understand that we want to work with the
public schools and I appreciate that
they're there for the children that need
them but this EFA fund is imperative to
my children's education and continues to
be imperative to all of the 1800 plus
children who have chosen to take part of
the AFA program because they are also
searching for the right fit in their
education choices and that is what the
efas have allowed for
us
absolutely thank
you
good
afternoon I believe that this bill
should not be passed because I believe
that everyone should be able to get the
education that they need and should be
provided with the things that they need
to get the best education they can this
bill will limit that and limiting that
will affect many people that cannot
afford public or private schools so I
believe that this
bill
I believe that this bill should not get
passed because it will affect several
people that are that cannot afford
public school or canot attend private
school because of said disabilities or
other problems that will prevent them
from going to other schools so passing
this bill will take so much from people
who cannot go to public or private
schools or can't afford to so passing
this bill will take education away from
so many children and I don't think that
anybody wants their kid to not have an
education I don't think anybody in this
room would want that so I believe that
this bill should not get passed so that
we can all be educated and be able to
have an education so that we can
you know live so the money that we use
for taxes is going to public schools and
private schools which you also have to
pay for just to get into so I don't
understand why we should limit what we
get and it's not going to affect the
public or the private schools like
intake because they're not limiting the
money that the public and the private
schools are taking in why should they
limit what we take in
you want to
speak I need money so I can get a new
working computer for school please don't
take my money
away hang on one
sec please say no to Bill
to
I'm shalomar inar I am the program and
Outreach coordinator for the children's
scholarship
fund Matt Southerton director of policy
in compliance for a children's
scholarship
fund uh I don't know if you just want me
to jump into this I have a few issues to
clear up that might uh help the
committee uh so I think that the data
that you were examining from earlier is
a bit
outdated the data that we have now shows
approximately half of the students that
are um participating in the EFA program
are uh a former public school students
students so that uh I think that the
number used earlier was
177% we have it a little under 50% you
might uh check with the Department of
Education to see if they can confirm
that I think that uh we might want to
examine the context when you speak about
money um you know you're debating $8
million and an education trust fund
that's actually $3 billion
another issue that when I examined this
bill at first that sort of came to my
mind was that this bill appears to be
retroactive so we're wondering if this
bill were to pass would this bill be
defunding 1,00 students low-income
families that currently receive the EFA
so how would we go about collecting that
money back from students that receed
that funding because approximately 70%
of those funds have already been
awarded um it looks like in fiscal year
22 you would limit the funding to three
$3,300
th000 so that would defund
approximately 1152
students so again how would we go about
telling those
students that they would no longer be
eligible for those funds
um in fiscal year
22 it would defund
1816 students again I don't know how we
would go about collecting those
funds
um oh another point that we were not
that I'm not sure that the committee
knows is that in order to be eligible
for the EFA you have to be eligible to
go to public school in New Hampshire so
people were talking about you know
you're your possible exposure
to um you know costs in the future well
you already have this exposure because
the students that are eligible for the
EFA are eligible to go to public school
students right so I've worked with
charter schools for 20 years and we see
students going to the charter school
going back to the traditional public
school and back and forth so populations
are somewhat transient you know we see
them moving back and forth so I think
that the the data that you have is is is
very very preliminary data it's very
very early for a a program that you know
is really
revolutionary and I don't think that
perhaps we knew that the need was going
to be so great and that that this this
program would be able to launch so
quickly and I am very thankful that it
did because I know that last year I was
receiving dozens and dozens of calls
from parents in my office um really
imploring for for um
you know spaces for their students in
charter schools and and I have family
that teaches in traditional Public
Schools so I'm a strong supporter as
well so anyway I just wanted to clear up
those issues and I'll turn it over
shelar thank you good afternoon Mr chair
and honorable members of the committee
um before I I proceed with some of the
information that I have here I do want
to let you know I speak directly with
the parents that have been um enrolled
in the program I am I guess what you
would call the boots on the ground I am
face Toof face talking on the phone
meeting with these parents and the
students and so I see firsthand the need
um for this program to exist we have so
many families that have received well
past the amount that this C proposes and
these families have already used their
EFA funds um and like Matt was saying if
we have to go ahead and retroactive umly
pay this back how would these families
that are 300% below the poverty level
expected to to pay this back that's kind
of cruel to do that um families that
need this program different types of
kids that are behind grade love on
struggling in their Public Schools um
but they thrive in the smaller classroom
at other schools whether it's a micro
School a home school a private school um
there are kids that and we all have to
admit this come on everybody let's admit
it in every school especially in the
public school systems there are kids
that are falling through the cracks and
we're catching those kids and we're
helping these kids because it's not fair
that these children have to suffer and
go throughout their lives feeling
inadequate and feeling like they can't
they're stupid they can't make it they
can't do it because they're not getting
the education that meets the needs that
they have not the ones that is is is as
a whole as a student that's saying okay
every student is this
way the kids whose's learning styles
that make remote learning extremely
difficult we know with the pandemic with
everything that's been going on I think
one of the biggest reasons why we got
more parents in and more families than
what we expected is a lot of these kids
just don't weren't doing well with the
remote learning I'm going to tell you a
little secret I tried to do the online
courses with college and I am horrible
at it call me traditional or whatever
but I need to be sited in a classroom
and I do better when I have the teacher
that can answer my questions so I can
only imagine what it's like for these
kids who just even though they're
techsavvy it's like they're born
nowadays knowing how to use a phone but
still it's still difficult for them and
expecting them to continue doing so if
they're not thriving is not fair to the
child either we also deal with kids um
that we have kids that are experiencing
racism and bullying um in their current
schools at CSF we've seen many cases
over the years about kids who have been
bullied and discriminated against
because of their skin color and we as an
organization have been so fortunate to
be able to bless these children and
these families with the funds to be able
to go to a school where they have
blossomed however today I we have a
story for you that happened recently and
that has shaken us to the core at
CSF the EFA program must be allowed to
continue Kaden is a 12-year-old old
child in seventh grade up until recently
he was in a national public school stud
uh
school he was assaulted by two other
students while a third student took a
video and uploaded it to Tik Tok which
incidentally showed a teacher standing
by not intervening Kaden was dragged to
the ground and then his head was
repeatedly stomped on by these other
students and still no one
intervened school authorities told the
parents well the teachers are not
allowed to intervene and are instructed
to wait for the school resource officer
to come and arrive and break up the
assault how is this a
thing had it not been for the existence
of the EFA program Kaden's grandfather
would have to had leave Kaden at the
mercy of these bullies and a system that
is unwilling to protect him so this
program helps thousands of students and
some are like Kaden who need emergency
access to resources of the EFA program I
ask that um you guys reconsider this
bill and think about yes we have a
bottom line there is money money's
always going to what is is to say money
makes the world go round but we also
have kids and we need to think of their
future not just in terms of public
school in terms of Education as a whole
thank
you yes represent cell uh thank you and
thank you for your testimony and um also
certainly for that story um uh you
received uh quite a few applications um
did you receive applications that um you
were not uh able to process because of
Eligibility such as the income
restrictions yes do you have an idea on
numbers he's the numbers
guy uh we did
receive we did receive a number of
applications that we were unable to
process they did not meet those
guidelines I believe it was uh under a
thank you chairman L um sir let me go
back to your your comment about the
change in the uh number of
50% uh compared to what we initially
received on the information from the
Department of Education uh and my
question is you indicated they were they
had been previously enrolled in public
school I think that's what you said that
that was
number so that that
number that number came from where
uh
hello I'm I'm might have a high time
hearing you as well oh I'm sorry Jen uh
did they explain to you what was wrong
it look is it a loose connection up
there yeah he did something in the back
there on that
one
all right so when a student no worries
so when a student applies for the EFA
they have to fill out a number of
financial forms Etc one of those is have
they attended a you know are they uh a
currently a home school or a a public
school student and and that all goes
into the i4c system the Department of
Education has all that data so that's
that's how we uh you know we know where
they're coming from and then we can load
that up to the Department of
Education yes you
may
yeah absolutely I don't have that with
me right now but I can certainly get
that information for
you
right
yeah right right absolutely so I guess
and and and the department could give
you exact numbers and and so could we I
just don't have them with you
today yes go
ahead
oh oh
absolutely
yeah absolutely oh for sure absolutely
and uh it is important to remember that
uh the the students are coming and going
all the time right so this is just a
snapshot of the DEA okay all
right yeah absolutely we'll have K
through 12 if
that's further
questions not seeing from the committee
thank you very much
and we have Brian Hawkins Nea New
Hampshire no why don't you Brian why
don't you go over and just bring a chair
up and sit right speaking to the you can
take one of those chairs right in front
to Jen's left
yeah it was working was just staticky
right
yeah all
right uh thank you very much uh Mr
chairman for the record Brian Hawkins
represented Nea New Hampshire today um I
think uh we're here uh we think the idea
of HB 1684 to budget for this program uh
which is a separate program um uh is a
is a good idea during the budget process
last year of the Senate um inserted the
contents of Senate Bill 130 uh into the
trailer bill of the budget um we think
that this short changed the thorough
fiscal analysis that we assume the house
would have done had they Advanced House
Bill 20 last year uh which was a similar
similar piece of legislation as you know
uh and had it gone through the normal
legislative process um as you know uh
the house never did its own uh impact
analysis of hb20 or Senate Bill 130 U
because they were never fully voted on
uh by the Full House as a standalone and
so they were never sent to house finance
um
unfortunately uh the lack of dedicated
time in a finance committee left the
department of education's estimates on
participation rate and cost without the
added scrutiny of the legislative budget
Assistance office um as had been done a
few years ago with Senate Bill 193 uh
which the legislature ultimately
rejected Ed um there were uh amendments
to that bill that explored different
types of caps uh uh to that to that
piece of
legislation um today uh this is a much
more expansive law than than that bill
was uh and we have a snapshot now of the
uh estimates versus the reality
um and you know we're seeing now that
there's a you know basically this 6200
per over or underestimate of the first
year of the program um and uh I I won't
go through all the same statistics I
think representative luno represented
those um before but next year's estimate
is 3.3 million um I think why that is uh
particularly important is because these
are the numbers that are carried on
the um on the balance sheet for the
State uh this is what the state assumes
when it uh assumes a BAL Surplus
statement um when it assumes that it has
passed a balanced budget so it's I think
it's important
process-wise that the legislature take a
look at budgeting this program going
forward um and uh so that that is a
concept we're we're very supportive of
in other states where they have a
program like this um it has started uh
those numbers have expanded quite a bit
but those expansions have largely come
because the legislature in those states
have ex has expanded the
eligibility um in New Hampshire we
started out with a very expansive
eligibility criteria um as was stated
earlier you just have to be a student
who is eligible to be a K12 student in
Hampshire so that's a very uh expansive
uh uh group of students so um so
starting out like that and especially if
the legislature is considering expanding
the
eligibility um as was I think mentioned
or alluded to earlier having those
budgeted amounts so you know what it is
the state is looking at going forward
would is important so I'll close my
testimony there and uh happy to take any
questions thank you very much Mr Hawkins
are there any questions
for for the
presenter not seeing any questions oh
yes one represent
um well I think there are a number of
programs in the state that have that
require an appropriation and so and I
think that I think the question needs to
be looked at and I think this is why
it's important to go through the the
full budgeting process with this is well
you know where where did those estimates
a on determining what is uh an
appropriate amount uh fortunately um the
legislature has different tools at its
disposal if there's a program needed uh
if there's more funding needed for a
particular program there are options
that that that the executive department
has to go before the fiscal committee or
some other type of committee to make an
argument why there need to be further
funding so I think I think it goes to
the and sometimes those are approved
sometimes those are not approved but it
it it forces I think the executive
branch to hold to hold to its amounts
and justify if need be you know why
those need to be exceeded so thank you
for the
question thank
you
there
helloo
hello hello hello
hello yeah maybe
this is the audio record here
obvious am I joining you Dave we can
just move the mic we'll just move the
mic put that
yeah
very
good don't we didn't
unplug I unplug oh I
see swap out oh d someone's helping
us
he1 two
two that cracking you're talking about
right still
doing
e
A1 two
two
one
microphone check one two
two
okay folks if we have these mics fixed
I'd like to get this hearing
going
okay okay we're ready to go ahead now
and this is the last bill for the day HB
1680 FN establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education and I welcome represent
luno maker of the bill and sitting
beside him we have Bill ardinger welcome
both of you again so thank you very much
Mr chair and members of the committee I
know it's been a long day of uh of a lot
of bills and uh and I wanted to um
express our thanks particularly for the
chair for uh for um setting us up with
um a 22 page bill at 3:30 in the
afternoon so um so but uh but with that
I think there's an opportunity for us to
um uh to work with with this committee
and provide a um um uh an introduction
to uh uh to this proposed legislation
and uh and before um bill and I sort of
get into it I wanted to sort of throw it
back to the chair to uh to talk a little
bit about the the road ahead which you
you started talking about this morning I
be glad to right now so we can quickly
um explain to the public where we're
going here uh there have been this is
the second Bill we have heard that we
are going to be setting up a
subcommittee a work session I've
announced earlier today the members
which will be on the subcommittee for
this particular Bill and that
subcommittee will meet its first time on
January the
24th and I believe that one is in the 10
a.m. 10 amm and then we have the other
committee meeting which is dealing with
tuition or or excuse me degrees offered
at the community college level that will
be at uh 1:00 in the afternoon on the
24th so we have a two-hour session set
there I'm sure due to the the uh amount
of information and data and data points
we're going to have to look at in terms
of this bill along with policy uh it's
going to take more than one meeting of a
subcommittee work session what we will
do then is invite those with technical
support and those who want to listen and
and observe you're welcome to come to
the sub committee meeting uh then it
will be brought back from uh the
subcommittee for recommendation uh at an
executive meeting to when we do uh
dispense with 1680 so that in the
nutshell is where we're going I think
it's the best way to address something
that's so comprehensive and and got so
much longlasting
uh need in this state and um so I look
forward I myself uh have not had an
opportunity to get down the nuts and
bolts of this I hope that we can get the
the 30,000 view right now and uh and
then later on during the subcommittee
get down into the weeds that's excellent
Mr chair thank you very much for that I
think that's a that's a a great way to
do this and that's um that's bill and my
my intention this afternoon to um uh to
introduce this uh talk about it at the
30,000 foot level we did pass out a
couple handouts um uh after I uh begin
the introduction uh Bill's going to walk
us through the this document right here
uh which um which cruises us through the
30 ,000 foot view of the bill um I also
uh we also handed out a a section by
section summary of the bill we do not
have intention to go through this today
but um uh but we we I think this would
probably be one of the first things we
tee up uh once we get into uh the work
sessions but uh but we thought we'd hand
it out today for everybody body's um
companion reading along with and and
just one other point I'd like to mention
to our public which listening streaming
and for those that are present here
today uh we have in front of us
represent luno and we have Bill uh
ardinger uh both served on the funding
commission study we had in the last year
or so and um bill was appointed to the
commission by governor sonunu and I
welcome you both and take us on this
trip thank you very much Mr chair um so
uh just for the record uh Dave luno here
um state representative serve on the
education committee and representing the
people of hopkington and conquered and
uh and to my right is Bill aringer
Bill thank you very much Mr chair and
committee members it's great to see you
happy New Year my name for the record is
Bill aringer I'm going to go a little
bit further than Dave well no no I've
got more to do I know but to be to be
clear about why why I'm here I'm an
attorney at wrath young and Pignatelli
in conquer uh um my firm and I represent
clients including in front of the
legislature I'm a registered lobbyist I
am not here today on behalf of my firm
any client or uh any lobbying activity I
am here in my own personal capacity as
Bill ardinger a resident of conquer I'm
very very pleased to be here I went to
public school in in Claremont New
Hampshire when my family moved to New
Hampshire I'm not a native at Stevens
High School and then I went to
University of New Hampshire I feel very
passionately about public schools and
that is why I was very pleased to be
appointed by Governor sonunu to uh the
the the commission that I served on with
uh chairman lad uh Dave luno uh dick
Ames I see and others it was a wonderful
experience and I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here with you uh and
with Dave to talk introduce this bill
for a review by the
committee oh I should say when I was in
college at 19 years old I was elected as
a member of this legislature from the
town of Cornish New Hampshire where my
family farmed still is I served one term
and loved it and I represented Cornish
and cin so it is one wonderful to be in
front and with you
today so thank you former member
ardinger um for that uh for that
introduction um so um just want to take
a few minutes to uh to uh set the
backdrop here and talk about some of the
recent work and challenges that uh that
have faced this legislature when it
comes to how New Hampshire funds its
schools but but starting at the top uh I
think we all know you've heard me say it
countless times but we've all read it
too New Hampshire students perform among
the best in the
country you know on average in New
Hampshire we're like top four top five
top six uh as a state uh in terms of in
terms of of uh student performance um uh
but um but unfortunately the way we fund
our schools is um is not fair for our
students or for taxpayers and um and as
a result of that
um while we're good on average as a
state it's just not happening everywhere
and um and one of the things that we
looked at um about a year and a half ago
during the commission's work was uh was
10 years of data collected by the
Department of Education and um all sorts
of data but but particularly student
student outcome data and uh uh one of
the real eye openening I I think this
was one of of the real eye openening
findings that uh that that data varies
widely and um uh while our average
student performance Statewide is very
strong the average student performance
in
Manchester and this isn't this isn't a
shot against Manchester's teachers or
their administrators or the
representatives um uh uh it's it's a
shot at how New Hampshire funds the
schools but the average student in
Manchester perform per at the fifth
percentile that means 95 out of every
hundred students in New Hampshire
performs better than the average student
in
Manchester at the same time you head out
uh towards the Sea Coast things change
dramatically the average student in
Oyster River performs closer to the 90th
percentile fifth percentile and 90th
percentile and a lot of this is as a
direct result of of how we fund our
schools local property tax rates vary
widely too uh from in some places less
than $3 per thousand um and uh to uh to
over $20 per thousand and um you know
while while some uh
districts uh for example the one that I
live in hopkington uh work super super
hard uh spend close to $20 per thousand
uh and we just barely can uh can afford
a satisfactory school budget we do have
a a fairly High performing um uh outcome
there's other districts that are working
a lot harder than we
are a district that might be 15 20
minutes up the road and uh and uh
working harder than $20 per thousand and
still come up well short of what they
need to uh to provide an adequate
education for um for their schools um
it's not because they don't want to
they're work working super hard to try
to do that they just can't get there
with the property valuations that they
have so that sort of brings us to to
recent work in this in this area I think
a lot of people remember five years ago
uh I think it was about five years ago
um there was an effort to uh to phase
out stabilization grants and where it
would be chipped away reduced at a at a
4% a year over 25 years and uh that
backfired pretty quickly um because uh
because these stabilization grants which
were put into the formula uh in in I
think
2011 uh really were there to shore up a
formula that didn't meet the needs of uh
of many of our um uh uh most um um
vulnerable districts and uh and so so I
think mayor Grenier probably wore out a
couple sets of tires you probably
remember this driving down to lob 207
talking about what Berlin was facing and
the challenges that they were facing
with uh with stabilization being shipped
away so so that got rectified and
stabilization got put back in at
100% um three years ago um uh chairman
lad and I uh worked together uh on House
Bill 709 and uh and uh we introduced a
fiscal capacity disparity Aid which had
been long ago in a uh into funding
formula and uh an enhanced Aid to
districts with higher concentrations of
um of lower income families um all these
Provisions made their way into the uh
the fy20 fy21 budget on a one-time basis
and the uh the uh uh the state um uh
actually at at for at the time had the
largest single year uh in uh increase in
um in U um uh contributions from the
education trust fund 625
million and then last year um House Bill
608 sponsored by uh by chairman lad um
sought to uh to also work within the
current framework of uh of school
funding and it ran into a lot of
challenges I mean Rick you and I talked
about that that bill quite a bit and uh
and uh removing stabilization uh posed a
lot of uh a lot of problems given the uh
given the current um you know fing
framework that that we see and then
there were additional bills Senate Bill
135 130
158 uh and even House Bill too that um
that uh put put actually considerable
State dollars into into the education
trust fund $685 million and um and at a
at a new record and uh for um for
support for public schools and FY 23 but
the problem is the framework doesn't
work um uh and um and what uh what we
found um during uh during during
commission work um is that um is that is
that New Hampshire has very much a a
flat costing and a flat funding model
that fails to take into consideration
the um the the the characteristics and
needs that our school districts across
the state have and we can take two very
two districts that are very close
together Benford and Manchester it costs
more to educate a thousand kids in
Manchester than it does a thousand kids
in
Bedford but New Hampshire school funding
formula doesn't recognize that and U and
it doesn't recognize that from a costing
perspective or a funding perspective
because New Hampshire pushes both these
two things together you cost it on a
flat basis and then everybody gets the
funding from the State against that cost
whether you're Manchester or
Bedford um so
um what uh what we're here to talk about
today is a is a new way to look at um at
school funding and it's new for New
Hampshire it's not new um nationally
other other states notably Massachusetts
are um are on their on their way to um
uh to a funding model similar to this
but it's called the foundation
opportunity program and it um it uh uh
it does two things very very well it
recognizes the cost differences that um
that that each district has given their
given the characteristics of the
students and the and the district and
the communities they serve um but it
also applies the state's limited
resources to where they're needed most
and um uh and and uh
uh and that helps to write the ship that
helps to improve fairness for both
students in terms of student outcomes
and taxpayers in terms of um in terms of
uh tax affordability so we're um we're
looking to uh again run through the um
uh the foundation opportunity program uh
at a fairly high level um where uh we're
very excited that uh that this committee
has decided to uh to bring this into uh
work sessions beginning on the 24th and
um and I'd like to hand it over to uh to
my my good friend Bill ardinger to uh to
take us through uh what the foundation
opportunity program is all
about and we will be happy to take
questions together and and again thank
you Mr chairman for this opportunity to
introduce this bill and then consider it
more carefully in a study committee I
will try to leave my remarks brief and
not get too much into the weeds provide
that that'll be tough for you won't it
Bill yes it's it's been hard for me all
my life so uh I'll start with a simple
uh thing that the commission focused on
the commission looked at New Hampshire
among the highest outcomes of public
schools in the nation on average among
the highest spending per
pupil in the nation on average however
when you take that lens with the help of
an expert and look around the state what
you see is that there are opportunity
gaps I went to school in Claremont when
we had very good businesses there they
closed after my wife and I my met my
wife in high school after we had
graduated and moved on the quality
available of public education in new
Hamp in Claremont fell what this study
clearly identified with data on outcomes
that wasn't available 20 years ago is
that there's a gap between the
opportunity for a quality traditional
public education in Claremont and other
communities compared to other places
like say Hanover and other communities
it is that opportunity Gap
that this complicated Bill focuses on
and takes the precious state budget
dollars that are currently in the budget
in the first year in the Surplus
statement and Rea portions those dollars
to try to give those school districts
what they need to close the opportunity
Gap and help the students who are
attending public schools there remember
our traditional common Public Schools
like the one my wife and I went to at
Stevens and Claremont educate over
95% of New Hampshire's children that's
the way we help children have access to
good happy lives but we know now based
on the work of the commission and the
expert analysis that we receive by
hiring a national expert that
opportunity gaps exist we've all known
this as people who care about New
Hampshire in our hearts we know there's
a difference between the public
education available in one place and
that available and say Claremont our job
and we had a wonderful who's a member of
this committee who's not here uh Mel
Meer representative Mel Miler who I had
never worked with before I was on this
commission and I've come to have great
faith in his heart and what he said is
even though and my wife and I we move
back we lived in conquer we raised our
three children in conquer my wife served
as uh president of the conquered school
board for 10 years and then she worked
on naming one of our K through five
schools Christa mlli school I see that
picture we all care about public schools
many of us have gone through them uh
what I find is that I can't sit there
even though conquer has a particular
quality of good Public Schools I can't
sit there knowing There's an opportunity
Gap in Claremont and representative
Miler said New Hampshire's children are
all of our children we have to work on
our school funding system to help aid
get directed to try and minimize
opportunity gaps so that all students
have the opportunity in New Hampshire
that they need to live a good life I'll
say that uh and Dave knows this and and
represent land I've been around the
state a long time I have helped uh Stan
Arnold when he was Department of Revenue
Commissioner helped uh Governor Shaheen
with the ABC program in 1999 and 2000
right after the second Claremont 2 case
came down I've worked with uh Senator
Fred King from colbrook one of the most
wonderful legislators he said let's just
use the State dollars that are precious
and focus them on places that need it
most I worked with Senator Carl Johnson
from the middle party who said Bill
can't we just take this money and focus
it on the communities who need it
most I worked with Governor John Lynch
who proposed an ee plan eei plan Ned
Gordon who's currently a rep was a
Senator supported this idea this is not
a Democrat or Republican idea the idea
of helping eliminate opportunity gaps is
one of our core responsibilities in the
state whether you're an elected official
as you all are or whether you're a
citizen who's benefited from the system
and cares about kids where we came from
this bill is all about that is it
complicated yes I would just like to
focus you please on three items Mr chair
and move on not walk through this thing
if you look at page
three what we see is a conclusion by the
expert at our
commission that in New
Hampshire the communities that have
higher relative
poverty have lower relative spending
capacity whereas in Massachusetts you
can see the line is
reversed is this on page three anyone
see the graph there this is right out of
the report of the expert I would say if
we knew how to win with statistics on a
good program New Hampshire's line would
tilt from the way it is there which is
regressive to A system that has got
greater resources available to the
communities who have greater uh poverty
in their communities I would like to
just focus on a comparison chart next if
you go to page seven
please page seven of that PowerPoint
let's see if we get there there's a
graph with
bubbles it's got two graphs one on the
top one on the bottom the top graph
shows the current system all the towns
are at about um right around 41 $100 per
pupil in terms of their aid from the
state and that's regardless of what
their equalized valuation is that's
almost a straight line that means in
Claremont where I know there are greater
challenges because I care deeply we won
the state championship when I was in
Claremont I was on basketball and
baseball teams I see representative
Allon who is a better basketball player
than I am and so is representative mafa
we played together in conquer
I would say that it's it's terrible that
Claremont is getting the same amount of
money per
pupil that Handover is getting there's
something wrong with that that's
different than any other state in the
country there's no precedent for that
how have we gotten there I'd like to
show you what the foundation opportunity
program does in the second graph in the
second graph you see that there's a
spread
some communities get as high as a
foundation budget of
$116,000 others have a foundation budget
of
8,000 this represents
a an opportunity for this program to say
I know there are opportunity gaps let's
focus the
resources that is the in a picture what
this program does I would now just like
to focus on one other page
page uh actually two page
10 everybody including the study
committee is going to ask how does the
math of this work how will there be
impacts in my community and other
communities well the formula is easy the
doe will determine a foundation
opportunity budget that's based on
outcomes and opportunity gaps every
Community will have have one it will
differ by
Community then there's a phas in period
it takes about 10 years there's an
amendment that has to be prepared that
representative luno representative Ames
other sponsors are working with uh to
get it out of legislative Services it
was very busy at ledge Services they're
great there but that that's getting done
but it's a 10-year phas
in how does a community get its
foundation opportunity budget paid two
sources one is it has a required
appropriation and that appropriation is
based takes into account its uh local
property tax base and if there's any Gap
left it gets a grant from the state
education trust fund and the sum total
of those grants in the first year with
the phas and proposed mean no increase
in the first year it is designed to try
and have the same amount of funds that
are currently being spent out of the
education trust fund carry forward in
that first year make no mistake about it
the foundation opportunity program is
designed to run over 10 years in a way
that says public education is our
state's top priority guess what it
already is it's the highest component of
spending State local plus the federal
component of any other priority in the
in the state state budget by far and
that is important why as Mel Miler said
because they're all our children I would
I would like to say that and then if we
go to fiscal impacts on page 11 the
LBA has got this bill they are becoming
familiar with it and they are working to
prepare a fiscal note thank you again to
Chairman lad to put into a work session
to allow LBA with the crush of bills
they've had you know nobody works harder
than LBA and and they're working to get
that we will see it but as I said one
important part is that it's designed to
fit within the general scheme of our
budget importantly some towns don't get
the same level of grant that they're
getting now however this bill recognizes
that you can't make unexpected impacts
on uh communities local District budgets
and it provides for transition grants
that would
protect communities from from drops in
their grants and that would phase in
Phase that that transition help would be
there for five years where would the
money come from that just like
Massachusetts has done they recognize
that public education has been one of
the most devastated institutions in our
society from Co and the federal dollar
that are available and I served on
gopher uh that that the committee the
advisory committee and I've helped
really Democratic and Republican
Governors do their budgets for 30 years
um those federal dollars would be used
to stabilize the transition to a fair
opportunity for all students in New
Hampshire uh the last uh on page 12 the
last slide I want to work on here is
just to identify that this bill also has
say property tax relief for low and
moderate income individual homeowners
you all haven't seen this bill but the
house Ways and Means Committee has
representative dick Ames has introduced
legislation that would strengthen and
clarify this property tax relief because
you know who really needs it the people
who have low and moderate incomes you
don't need to Grant property tax relief
to people who own million dooll
properties they can pay the same rate
that we all pay for the State Property
Tax but let me tell you right now in our
current law there is a bomb that's
waiting to explode in our face and that
is we do not collect excess State
Property Tax from Whole towns what that
means is there are different rates being
paid our constitution is so strong wrong
in protecting that all taxpayers must
pay tax at the same rate that that is a
risk to our state's public Fisk this
bill would focus on fixing that problem
and then making sure that taxpayers in
towns that would see a tax increase when
they're low in moderate income they get
relief and this is wound into this bill
too that is a quick overview of this
bill the PowerPoint and the section by
section is available for everyone the
public to look at I would close Mr Chair
by
saying every time public education
funding has been done in the state since
Claremont 2 it's been a crisis it's been
out of control it's been raced it has
not had clear guidance on principles but
this bill does it is integrated it is
got a lot of thought it is neither
Republican nor Democrat
it is about Fair funding that
solves the opportunity gaps that we have
in our state and I I I I couldn't say
this more
passionately that that rather than wait
for the crisis to hit
us we thank this committee for starting
on the road towards a
planned smart replacement for the
current unfair broken and very likely
unconstitutional system thank you Dave
would you like to close
that's um thanks thanks Bill and thanks
um uh to all of you for uh for um uh
being here throughout the uh throughout
the day and into the afternoon to allow
us toh to present this bill and my
thanks again to um to to Rick for to the
chair to uh to put this to uh to work
sessions and uh and of course I've got
to thank um you know know my uh my my
colleagues Bill dick Ames Mel Meer uh
Mary Heath and chairman lad for um uh
for for their work uh serving on the
school funding commission and um and
really I think Opening Our Eyes to um to
uh some of the challenges that we're
facing in terms of how we go about uh
how we're currently funding schools and
uh and helping us um really sort of see
opportunities uh uh for uh for ways of
of improving that not just not just for
next year or two years but for uh for
decades uh decades to come and uh you
know one of the things Bill Bill didn't
mention uh but alluded to is that uh is
that you know we're we're at the
beginning of this road yeah the
commission did work but we're at the
beginning now of the legislative process
we're not coming to you coming to this
committee with a fully cooked ready too
um you know meal prep kit this is um
this is something that we can work on uh
together and it's important that we get
started now because there's another shoe
to drop do you want to do you want to
talk the conell you do so well I'm not
as equipped to do it as as our attorney
uh U let me try quickly you all know the
conille case is pending you know that
the judge the local judge concluded that
the current system on the spending
funding side was unconstitutional it
went to the New Hampshire Supreme Court
they said you got to hold a trial that
trial is in summer of
22 that judge will then look at the
question is
$397 an adequate funding level to
satisfy the Constitutional obligation we
don't know how that's going to come out
but there's a risk that that Court could
conclude after trial that it's not
enough and then it'll go on appeal to
the Supreme Court you know whether that
will go because it's gone there every
time the court will look at it and it'll
remind the legislature again of its
leadership role in establishing a sound
fair system for funding public education
in New Hampshire and that's why it's
important that this commission did all
the work it did uh has produced a
recommendation and is not just sitting
on its Laurels but bringing it forward
to let this committee start work before
there's a problem arising from the
conville case or the Statewide property
tax case and I do want to say right here
I did note not only that representative
Ellison was better at conquered
basketball to me but representative
Moffett was much better whether it's on
the gaslighter or Joe Kings it's good to
see you guys so great um thanks and
we're happy to take uh take some
questions thank you very much and uh I
appreciate your being able to give the
overview of where this particular bill
is going or would like to go uh a lot of
work to be done the Gap is too large we
got to as you say so I hope we can come
up with something positive we have
certainly tried over the years since
I've been in this house and prior to my
being in the house I don't know how many
task force how many committees I do know
how many and I just don't know if I can
count that all in one hand and with the
commission good stuff in in various
parts of all that and but uh we just
been chipping around the side and having
gotten to where we need to go somehow we
have to do that and let's put a good
foot forward here and at this point in
time we'll open this up to questions
from those sitting here on the committee
representative bone
thank you Mr chairman just one question
something probably we need for our work
session tax rates are only half the
problem the cost average cost of housing
is the other half for example $300,000
house where I live may only be $100,000
house in Berlin so if their tax rate is
three times more we're paying the same
taxes so that's something we need to
work on look
at okay thank thank you very much much
thank
youal further questions or
statements yes
representative ruoff I think so it's a
Judge David R
ruoff and I and and that has moved from
chesher yes to Rockingham I'm not a
litigator but it did move is it is it in
Rock
yeah so that and it's in he kept control
of the case when it when he moved and so
yes it's judge R represent leus do you
have a
question um it's more of a well it is
sort of a question I'm
wondering
um a lot of this is about money and
getting money to districts but are you
going to in the subcommittee and
figuring this out how that money is
actually going to help because what I've
noticed there's a strong correlation
between the academic maximum the
academic level of the parents and the um
achievement of the children and the
question is how is this money that
you're giving how are you going to make
it hold the towns accountable to use it
for something that's going to actually
work to help bridge that Gap I see that
as a much bigger Gap right and
representative leakas thank you very
much for that question that's a very
important point and I think you you you
tied the money into into accountability
and student outcomes very very well
that's one of the things that I think
we're most um excited about when it
comes to the foundation opportunity plan
because unlike an accountability system
that's based on a bag of things like 30
chairs and a teacher and one principal
for every 500 kids and stuff like that I
mean you could certainly add all those
things up and find out if a district is
spending their money on those things but
to be able to um measure the uh the
student performance and uh and hold
districts accountable uh based on that
and um and there's an entire section in
the um um in in uh 1680 uh on
accountability uh that uh that is that
that that um ties back to Performance it
ties back to data collection from the
Department uh so that we can continue to
improve our ability to uh to measure
student outcomes and um and support
districts so that uh student outcomes
meet the um meet the the outcome
standard that we've defined for an
adequate
education yeah may I add just one I
thought an excellent question I agree uh
thank you for it I want to say that the
court in
Clara Supreme Court in those Clara cases
has always said you can't have a system
that satisfies the Constitutional duty
to provide a decent public education
without an accountability system we've
struggled for years to have an
accountability system because the data
measuring outcomes has been new and
hesitant in our committee meetings it
was clear that for the first time we
have built a database of outcomes data
that allows a check on whether the
outcome Gap the opportunity Gap has been
closed and this is require this bill
requires every 10 years a recalculation
that is transparent and produces data
that the public the legislature courts
can look at to see whether there's a
closing of the opportunity Gap that is a
something that has been missing in past
uh efforts to resolve this horrible
problem that has drained energy of great
elected officials for so long we should
fix
it are there further
questions thank you very much great
thank you very much Mr
chairman were there any other
cards okay somebody else is very
familiar with this process uh I'd like
to invite Jeff
mcclinch thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you members of the committee uh
for the opportunity to testify this
afternoon on House Bill 1680 in view of
the hour I'll attempt to be brief um and
just try to hit some key points for the
record my name is Jeff mcclinch and I'm
the Project Director of the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project as the members of the committee
have just heard uh New Hampshire's
school funding system suffers at present
from a pair of injustices and has for
some time both deep in enduring
inequities an educational opportunity
and enormous differences in the property
taxes we pay as residents and business
owners to support Public Schools the
tremendous gap between what the state
has determined be the cost of an
adequate education about $4,700 per
pupil and the cost communities actually
face roughly $199,300 per student on
average as of the most recent data are
glaring Testament to these injustices as
our school property tax rates that range
from
$227 uh cents to
$20.89 per thousand of value these two
injustices arise from a single Source
the state of New Hampshire has failed
for decades AES to fulfill its
fundamental constitutional
responsibility to provide an adequate
education to every child within its
borders instead it has shifted that
responsibility onto local property
taxpayers forcing them to Bear
approximately $2.3 billion dollar in
costs each year costs that should be met
with State revenues the only way to
revenue these injustices is to end that
downshifting and to create a system that
enables the state of New Hampshire to
meet at long last its core educational
responsibilities the bill before you
this afternoon 1680 would take
meaningful steps towards alleviating
some of the disparities now emic in
Hampshire school funding system and I
don't want to belabor these points
because I'm H happy to hear that there's
going to be a a study committee that
looks at this or subcommittee but there
are three changes in particular it stand
out first consistent with as you've
heard rigorous statistical analyses
conducted by the American Institutes of
research the bill would modify the
current adequacy Aid formula to ensure
that the distribution of such Aid better
reflects the need needs of school
districts and the student populations
they
serve second 1680 would mitigate some of
the variation in school property tax
rates now faced by different homeowners
and businesses in different parts of the
state by requiring municipalities to
perit the full amount of the existing
Statewide property tax to the state
treasury third the bill at ease the
economic hardship school property taxes
can create for low-income granted
Staters by expanding eligibility for the
existing homeowners property tax relief
program and by substantially increasing
the value of the rebates the program
pays out nevertheless as it's currently
written H Bill 1680 would fall short of
attaining the kind of comprehensive
reform needed to ensure the state of New
Hampshire fulfills its constitutional
responsibility to provide an adequate
education to every child in particular
an establishing a minimum Foundation
budget contribution equal in some cases
to $5 per thousand of value the bill
would require local property taxpayers
to continue to help find Finance the
provision of inadequate education a duty
that lies squarely with the state as the
Supreme Court made abundantly clear in
its 2006 lary ruling whatever the state
identifies as comprising constitutional
adequacy it must pay for none of that
financial obligation can be shifted to
local school districts regardless of
their relative wealth or need in
addition in making the changes noted to
the U current adequacy Formula the bill
likely or ultimately entails an increase
in the total amount of it such the state
may distribute in a given year though as
was uh acknowledged there's not yet a
fiscal note on the bill so the extent of
that increase isn't known over time now
to be sure the state should be
increasing uh St such Aid so that
localities are not forced to pay the
Lion Share of cost for public education
however beyond the restoration of the
swept as a true Statewide tax the bill
does not appear to include a permanent
state revenue source to support any such
increase in Aid so in closing I'm
heartened to hear that uh the the bill
will be continue to be considered uh in
a subcommittee and I hope that U we at
the school funding fairness project will
have a chance to work with the sponsors
of the bill and all the members of this
committee and that subcommittee um to
address these concerns and ultimately to
build a school funding system that
fulfills the State's responsibilities
and leads to Greater equity for students
and taxpayers like again I thank you for
the chance to be here this afternoon and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
might have uh thank you very much Jeff
do you have a a copy of is that your
presentation you've been flipping to
decide you should have you have a cop
you there Y for the okay great I just
I've emailed a copy to the committee and
to and to thank you are there questions
from the
committee I don't see any hands up I
know I'm standing between you and home
so no it's just a huge task uh it
certainly is and there's a long path
that has to be taken so um we'll work
towards it um so no further questions
and I don't see are there any other
cards which we have here so we don't
have that so we will close this hearing
and and as I stated for I am appointing
I have appointed a subcommittee to move
forward on this those subcommittee
members have been notified and we will
meet on January
24th thank you very much this this
hearing is
closed
did you get a copy of
thiso oh so wait so I need one too did
you get one for the record did okay they
all had them they all have them okay so
okay so we'll just keep one extra up
here
okay
work
e